no excuses
by brian tracy
read by the author
introduction the miracle of
self-discipline
mark twain said that there are a
thousand excuses for failure
but never a good reason
why are some people more successful than
others
why do some people make more money live
happier lives and accomplish much more
in the same number of years than the
great majority
what is the real secret of success
often i begin a seminar with a little
exercise
i ask the audience how many people here
would like to double their incomes
almost everyone smiles and raises their
hands i then ask how many people here
would like to lose weight
get out of debt achieve financial
independence
again everyone smiles some people cheer
and they all raise their hands then i
say wonderful these are great goals that
everyone has we all want to make more
money spend more time with our families
be fit and trim and achieve financial
independence
not only do we all want the same things
but we all know what we have to do to
achieve them and we all intend to do
those things sometime but before we get
started we decide that we need to take a
little vacation to a wonderful fantasy
place called
someday isle
we say that someday i'll read that book
someday i'll start that exercise program
someday i'll upgrade my skills and earn
more money someday i'll get my finances
under control and get out of debt
someday i'll do all the things that i
know i need to do to achieve all my
goals
someday
probably eighty percent of the
population lives on someday isle most of
the time
they think and dream and fantasize about
all the things they're going to do
someday
and who are they surrounded by on
someday isle
other people on someday aisle and what
is the chief topic of conversation on
sunday isle
excuses
they all sit around and swap excuses for
being on the island
why are you here they ask each other
and not surprisingly their excuses are
largely the same
i didn't have a happy childhood i didn't
get a good education i don't have any
money
my boss is really critical
my marriage is no good no one
appreciates me or the economy is
terrible
they have come down with the disease of
excusitis which is invariably fatal to
success
they all have good intentions but as
everyone knows the road to hell is paved
with good intentions
the first rule of success is simple
vote yourself off the island no more
excuses do it or don't do it but don't
make excuses stop using your incredible
brain to think up elaborate
rationalizations and justifications for
not taking action
do something do anything get on with it
repeat to yourself if it's to be it's up
to me
losers make excuses winners make
progress
now how can you tell if your favorite
excuse is valid or not it's simple
look around and ask is there anyone else
who has my same excuse who is successful
anyway
when you ask this question if you're
honest you'll have to admit that there
are thousands and even millions of
people who've had it far worse than you
who have gone on to do wonderful things
with their lives and what thousands and
millions of other people have done you
can do as well if you try
it's been said that if people put as
much energy into achieving their goals
as they spend making up excuses for
failure they would actually surprise
themselves
but first
you have to vote yourself off the island
very few people start off with many
advantages
personally i did not graduate from high
school i worked at laboring jobs for
several years
i had a limited education limited skills
and a limited future
and then i began asking that question
why are some people more successful than
others
this question changed my life
over the years i've read thousands of
books and articles on the subjects of
success and achievement it seems that
the reasons for these accomplishments
have been discussed and written about
for more than two thousand years in
every conceivable way
one quality that most philosophers
teachers and experts agree on is the
importance of
self-discipline discipline is what you
must have to resist the lure of excuses
it is self-discipline that enables you
to vote yourself off the island
it is the key to a great life and
without it no lasting success is
possible
the development of self-discipline
changed my life and it will change yours
as well
by continually demanding more from
myself
i became successful in sales and then in
management
i caught up on my schooling and took an
mba degree in my 30s which required
thousands of hours of determined study
i imported suzuki vehicles into canada
before anyone else set up 65 dealerships
and sold 25 million dollars worth of the
vehicles
and this is all after i had started with
no knowledge of the industry
what i had however was the discipline
and determination to learn what i needed
to know
and then to apply
and do what i needed to do
i got into real estate development with
no knowledge or experience
applied the power of discipline which
was then backed by hundreds of hours of
work and study
i then went on to build shopping centers
industrial parks office buildings and
residential
subdivisions with self-discipline i have
built successful businesses in training
consulting speaking writing recording
and distribution
my audio and video programs books
seminars and training programs have sold
more than 500 million dollars worth in
36 languages in 54 countries
over the years i've consulted for more
than a thousand companies and trained
more than 5 million people in live
seminars and talks
in every case the practice of
self-discipline has been essential to my
success
i discovered that you can achieve almost
any goal you set for yourself if you
have the discipline to pay the price to
do what you need to do and to never give
up
so who should read this book
this book is written for ambitious
determined men and women who want to
achieve everything that is possible for
them in life
it is written for people who are hungry
to do more to have more and to be more
than they ever have been before
perhaps the most important insight of
all with regard to success
is that to achieve greatly you must
become a different person
it is not the material things you
accomplish or require that matter so
much as it is the quality of the person
that you must become to accomplish well
above the average
the development of self-discipline is
the high road that makes everything
possible for you
this book will serve as your
step-by-step guide to becoming a
remarkable person who is capable of
making remarkable achievements
a chance encounter reveals the reason
for success
some years ago i was attending a
conference in washington dc during the
lunch break i was eating at a nearby
food fair
the area was crowded so i sat down at
the last open table by myself even
though it was a table for four
a few minutes later an older gentleman
and a younger woman who appeared to be
his assistant came along
carrying trays of food and obviously
looking for a place to sit
having lots of room at my table i
immediately arose and invited the older
gentleman to join me
he was hesitant but i insisted finally
he sat down quite thankfully and we
began to chat over lunch
it turned out that his name was cop
copmeyer as it happened i immediately
knew who he was he was a legend in the
field of success and achievement cop
copmeyer had written four best-selling
books
each of which contained 250 success
principles that he had derived from more
than 50 years of research and study
i had read all four books from cover to
cover each more than once
after we had chatted for a while i asked
him the question that many people in
this situation would ask
of all the 1000 success principles that
you have discovered which do you think
is the most important
he smiled at me with a twinkle in his
eye as if he had been asked this
question many times and he replied
without hesitating
the most important success principle of
all was stated by albert hubbard one of
the most prolific writers in american
history at the beginning of the 20th
century he said
self-discipline is the ability to do
what you should do
when you should do it whether you feel
like it or not
he went on to say there are 999 other
success principles that i have found in
my reading and experience
but without self-discipline
none of them work
with self-discipline they all work
thus self-discipline is the key to
personal greatness it's the magic
quality that opens all doors for you and
makes everything else possible
with self-discipline the average person
can rise as far and as fast as his
talents and intelligence can take him
but without self-discipline
a person with every blessing of
background education and opportunity
will seldom rise above mediocrity
your two worst enemies
just as self-discipline is the key to
success
the lack of self-discipline is the major
cause of failure frustration
underachievement and unhappiness in life
it causes us to make excuses and sell
ourselves short
perhaps the two biggest enemies of
success happiness and personal
fulfillment are first the path of least
resistance and second the expediency
factor
the path of least resistance is what
causes people to take the easy way in
almost every situation
they seek shortcuts to everything
they arrive at work at the last minute
and leave at the first opportunity
they look for get rich quick schemes and
easy money
over time they develop the habit of
always seeking an easier faster way to
get the things they want rather than
doing what is hard but necessary to
achieve real success
the expediency factor which is an
extension of the law of least resistance
is even worse when leading people to
failure and under achievement
this principle says
people invariably seek the fastest and
easiest way to get the things they want
right now with little or no concern for
the long-term consequences of their
behaviors
in other words most people do what is
expedient what is fun and easy rather
than what is necessary for success
every day and every minute of every day
there's a battle going on inside of you
between doing what is right hard and
necessary
like the angel on one shoulder
or doing what is fun easy and a little
or no value like the devil on your other
shoulder
every minute of every day you must fight
and win this battle with the expediency
factor and resist the pull of the path
of least resistance if you truly desire
to become everything you are capable of
becoming
take control of yourself
another definition of self-discipline is
self-mastery
success is only possible when you can
master your own emotions appetites and
inclinations
people who lack the ability to master
their appetites become weak and
dissolute as well as unreliable in other
things as well
self-discipline can also be defined as
self-control
your ability to control yourself and
your actions control what you say and do
and ensure that your behaviors are
consistent with your long-term goals and
objectives is the mark of the superior
person
discipline has been defined as
self-denial
this requires that you deny yourself the
easy pleasures the temptations that lead
so many people astray
and instead discipline yourself to do
only those things that you know are
right for the long term
and appropriate for the moment
self-discipline requires delayed
gratification the ability to put off
satisfaction in the short term
in order to enjoy greater rewards in the
long term
think long term
sociologist dr edward badfield of
harvard university conducted a 50-year
study into the reasons for upward
socioeconomic mobility in america
he concluded that the most important
single attribute of people who achieved
great success in life was
long time perspective
banfield defined time perspective
as the amount of time an individual
takes into consideration when
determining his present actions
in other words the most successful
people are long-term thinkers
they look into the future as far as they
can to determine the kind of people they
want to become and the goals they want
to achieve
they then come back to the present and
determine the things that they will have
to do or not do to achieve their desired
futures
this practice of long-term thinking
applies to work career marriage
relationships money and personal conduct
each of which is covered in the pages
ahead
successful people make sure that
everything they do in the short term
is consistent with where they want to
end up in the long term
they practice self-discipline at all
times
perhaps the most important word in
long-term thinking is sacrifice
superior people have the ability
throughout their lives to make
sacrifices in the short term both large
and small
so as to assure greater results and
rewards in the long term
you see this willingness to sacrifice in
people who spend many hours and even
years preparing studying and upgrading
their skills to make themselves more
valuable
so that they can have a better life in
the future
rather than spending most of their time
socializing and having fun in the
present
longfellow once wrote
those heights by great men won and kept
were not achieved by sudden flight
but they
while their companions slept
were toiling upward in the night
your ability to think plan and work hard
in the short term and to discipline
yourself to do what is right and
necessary before you do what is fun and
easy is the key to creating a wonderful
life for yourself
your ability to think long term is a
developed skill
as you get better at it you become more
able to predict with increasing accuracy
what is likely to happen to you in the
future as the result of your actions in
the present
this is a quality of the superior
thinker
short-term gain can cause long-term pain
there are two laws that you fall victim
to when you fail to practice
self-discipline
the first is called the law of
unintended consequences
this law states that the unintended
consequences of an action can be far
worse than the intended consequences of
that behavior because of a lack of
long-term thinking
the second law is the law of perverse
consequences
which says that a short-term action
aimed at immediate gratification
can lead to perverse or the opposite
consequences from those at which it was
aimed
for example you might make an investment
of time money or emotion with a desire
and intent to be better off and happier
as a result
but because you acted without carefully
thinking or doing your homework the
consequences of your behavior turned out
to be far worse than if you had done
nothing at all
every person has had this experience and
usually more than once
the common denominator of success
herbert gray a businessman conducted a
long-term study searching for what he
called the common denominator of success
after 11 years he finally concluded that
the common denominator of success was
that
successful people make a habit of doing
the things that unsuccessful people
don't like to do
and what were these things
it turned out that the things that
successful people don't like to do
are the same things that failures don't
like to do either
but successful people do them anyway
because they know that this is the price
they will have to pay if they want to
enjoy greater success and rewards in the
future
what gray found was that successful
people are more concerned with pleasing
results whereas failures were more
concerned about pleasing methods
successful happy people were more
concerned with the positive long-term
consequences of their behaviors
whereas unsuccessful people were more
concerned with personal enjoyment and
immediate gratification
motivational speaker dennis waitley has
said that the top people were those who
were more concerned with activities that
were goal achieving
whereas average people were more
concerned with activities that were
tension relieving
dinner before dessert
the simplest rule in the practice of
self-discipline is to eat dinner before
dessert
in a meal there is a logical order of
dishes and dessert comes last
first you eat the main courses and clean
your plate only then do you have dessert
there's a cute but misleading bumper
sticker that says
life is short eat dessert first
just think about what would happen if
you came home from work and
instead of eating a healthy dinner you
ate a large piece of apple pie with ice
cream
what kind of appetite for healthy
nutritious food would you have afterward
with all that sugar in your stomach how
would you feel
would you feel re-energized and eager to
do something productive
or would you feel tired and sluggish and
ready to write off the day is largely
finished
you get the same results when you go for
a drink or two after work and then come
home and turn on the television
these are simply different forms of
dessert that largely eliminate your
ability to do anything useful for the
rest of the evening
perhaps the worst part of all is that
whatever you do repeatedly soon becomes
a habit
and a habit once formed is hard to break
the habit of taking the easy way of
doing what is fun and enjoyable or
eating dessert before dinner becomes
stronger and stronger and it leads
inevitably to personal weakness
underachievement and failure
the habit of self-discipline
fortunately you can develop the habit of
self-discipline
the regular practice of disciplining
yourself to do what you should do when
you should do it whether you feel like
it or not becomes stronger and stronger
as you practice it
you simply refuse to make excuses
bad habits are easy to form but hard to
live with
good habits are hard to form
but easy to live with
and as good as said
everything is hard before it's easy
it's hard to form the habits of
self-discipline self-mastery and
self-control but once you've developed
them they become automatic and easy to
practice
when the habits of self-discipline are
firmly entrenched in your behavior you
start to feel uncomfortable when you're
not behaving in a self-disciplined
manner
the best news is that all habits are
learnable
you can learn any habit you need to
learn in order to become the kind of
person that you want to become
you can become an excellent person by
practicing self-discipline whenever it's
called for every practice of
self-discipline strengthens every other
discipline
unfortunately every weakness in
discipline weakens your other
disciplines as well
to develop the habit of self-discipline
you first make a firm decision about how
you will behave in a particular area of
activity
you then refuse to allow exceptions
until the habit of self-discipline in
that area is firmly established
each time you slip as you will you
resolve once again to keep practicing
self-discipline until it becomes easier
for you to behave in a disciplined way
than to behave in an undisciplined way
the big payoff
the payoff for developing high levels of
self-discipline is extraordinary
there is a direct relationship between
self-discipline and self-esteem
the more you practice self-mastery and
self-control the more you like and value
yourself
the more you discipline yourself the
greater is your sense of self-respect
and personal pride
the more you practice self-discipline
the better is your self-image you see
yourself and think about yourself in a
more positive way you feel happier and
more powerful as a person
the development and maintenance of the
habit of self-discipline is a lifelong
task an ongoing battle it never ends
the temptation to follow the path of
least resistance and the expediency
factor lurk continually in the back of
your mind
they are always waiting for an
opportunity to pounce to lead you astray
into doing what is fun easy and
unimportant rather than what is hard
necessary and life enhancing
napoleon hill concluded his best-selling
book of the same name by saying that
self-discipline is the master key to
riches
self-discipline is the key to
self-esteem self-respect and personal
pride
the development of self-discipline is
your guarantee that you will eventually
overcome all your obstacles and create a
wonderful life for yourself
the ability to practice self-discipline
is the real reason why some people are
more successful and happy than others
how this book is written in the pages
ahead i will describe the 21 areas in
life in which the practice of
self-discipline is vital to fulfilling
your full potential and achieving
everything that is possible for you this
book is divided into three sections for
greater ease of use
part one is entitled self-discipline and
personal success
in these seven chapters you will learn
how to release more and more of your
personal potential by practicing
self-discipline in every area of your
personal life
including setting goals building
character accepting responsibility
developing courage and backing
everything you do with persistence and
determination
in the seven chapters of part two you
will learn how to achieve vastly more
than ever before in the areas of
business sales and personal finance
you learn why and how self-discipline is
essential to becoming a leader in your
field to
operating a business more profitably to
making more sales
investing more intelligently and
managing your time for maximum results
finally in the seven chapters of part
three you will learn how to apply the
miracle of self-discipline to your
personal life
you will learn how to practice
self-discipline in the areas of
happiness health
fitness
marriage children friendship and the
attainment of peace of mind
you will learn how to enhance the
quality of your life in your
relationships in every area
in each chapter i will show you how you
can incorporate higher levels of
self-discipline and self-mastery into
everything you do
in the pages ahead you will learn how to
take complete control over your own
personal and professional development
and how to become a stronger happier
more self-confident person in every area
of your life that is important to you
you will learn how to break old habits
that may be holding you back and how to
develop the habits of self-reliance
self-determination and self-discipline
that will enable you to set and achieve
any goal
you'll learn how to take complete
control over your mind your emotions and
your future
when you master the power of
self-discipline you will become
unstoppable like a force of nature
you will never make excuses for not
making progress you will accomplish more
in the next few months and years than
most people accomplish in a lifetime
part one
self-discipline and personal success
your success in life depends more on the
person you become than on the things you
do or acquire
as aristotle wrote the ultimate end of
life is the development of character
in these chapters you will learn how to
develop and use discipline in order to
become an excellent person
you'll learn how to develop greater
self-esteem self-respect and personal
pride
you will learn the essential disciplines
required for personal greatness and how
to build them into your own character
and personality
chapter one
self-discipline and success
plato wrote
the first and best victory is to conquer
self
why do some people accomplish so much
more in their personal and professional
lives than others
this question has occupied some of the
very best minds throughout human history
more than 2
300 years ago aristotle wrote that the
ultimate aim of human life is to be
happy
he said that the great question that
each of us must answer is
how shall we live in order to be happy
your ability to ask and answer that
question correctly for yourself and then
to follow where your answer leads you
will largely determine whether you
achieve your own happiness and how soon
begin with your own personal definition
how do you define success
if you could wave a magic wand and make
your life perfect in every way
what would it look like
describe your ideal life
if your business work and career were
ideal in every way what would they look
like what would you be doing what sort
of a company would you work for what
position would you have
how much money would you earn
what kind of people would you work with
and especially what would you need to do
more or less of to create your perfect
career
if your family life were perfect in
every way what would it look like
where would you live and how would you
be living
what kind of a lifestyle would you have
what sort of things would you want to
have and do with the members of your
family if you had no limitations and you
could wave a magic wand in what ways
would you change your family life today
if your health were perfect how would
you describe it how would you feel
how much would you weigh
how would your levels of health and
fitness be different from what they are
today
most of all what steps could you take
immediately to begin moving toward your
ideal levels of health and energy
if your financial situation were ideal
how much would you have in the bank
how much would you be earning each month
and each year from your investments
if you had enough money so that you
never had to worry about finances again
how much would that be
and what steps could you take starting
today to create your ideal financial
life
do your own thing
a popular definition of success is being
able to live your life in your own way
doing only those things that you want to
do with the people who you choose in the
situations you desire
in each case when you begin to define
what success means to you you can
immediately see things that you should
be doing more of or less of in order to
begin creating your ideal life
and the biggest thing that holds you
back from moving in the direction of
your dreams
is usually a lack of self-discipline and
your favorite excuses
it's not that you don't know what to do
but rather that you don't have the
discipline to make yourself do what you
should do whether you feel like it or
not
join the top 20 percent
in our society the top 20 percent of
people earn eighty percent of the money
and enjoy eighty percent of the riches
and rewards
this pareto principle has been proven
over and over again since it was first
formulated in 1895 by vilfredo pareto
your first goal in your career should be
to get into the top 20 in your chosen
field
in the 21st century there's a premium on
knowledge and skill
the more knowledge you acquire and the
greater skill that you apply
the more competent and valuable you
become
as you get better at what you do your
income earning ability increases like
compound interest
unfortunately the majority of people the
bottom eighty percent make little or no
effort to upgrade their skills
most people according to jeffrey
colvin's 2009 book talent is overrated
learn their jobs in the first year of
their employment and then
they never get any better
it is only the top people in every field
who are committed to continuous
improvement
because of this increasing disparity of
productive ability based on knowledge
skill and hard work
the top one percent of people in america
today control as much as 33 percent of
the financial assets
starting with nothing
interestingly almost everyone starts out
the same in life with little or nothing
almost all fortunes in america and
worldwide are first generation this
means that most individuals started with
little or nothing and earn everything
they own in their current lifetime
the wealthiest people in america are
almost all first-generation
multi-billionaires
this is the case with wealthy americans
such as bill gates warren buffett larry
ellison michael dell and paul allen
fully 80 percent of millionaires and
multi-millionaires started with little
money often penniless and sometimes
deeply in debt with few advantages such
as sam walton who died worth more than
100 billion dollars
why have these people been able to
achieve so much when so many have
achieved so little
in their book the millionaire next door
thomas stanley and william danko
interviewed more than 500 millionaires
and surveyed 11 000 more over a 25-year
period
they asked them why they felt they had
been able to achieve financial
independence
when most of the people around them who
started at the same place were still
struggling
fully 85 percent of this new generation
of millionaires replied by saying
something like
i didn't have a better education or more
intelligence
but i was willing to work harder than
anyone else
hard work is the key
the indispensable requirement for hard
work is self-discipline
success is only possible when you can
overcome the natural tendency to cut
corners and take the easy way
lasting success is only possible when
you can discipline yourself to work hard
for a long long time
as i mentioned in the introduction
i started my own life with no money or
advantages
for years i worked at laboring jobs at
which i earned just enough to get from
paycheck to paycheck
i stumbled into sales when i could no
longer find a laboring job where i spun
my wheels for many months before i begin
asking that question
why is it that some people are more
successful in selling than others
one day a top salesman told me that the
top twenty percent of sales people earn
eighty percent of the money
i had never heard that rule before
this meant that the bottom eighty
percent of salespeople had to be
satisfied with the remaining twenty
percent with what was left over after
the top people had taken the lion's
share
i decided then and there that i was
going to be in the top 20
and this decision changed my life
the great law
then i learned the iron law of the
universe which made getting into the top
twenty percent possible
it was the law of cause and effect or
sowing and reaping
this law says that for every effect
there is a specific cause or series of
causes
this law says that if you want to
achieve success in any area you must
determine how success is achieved in
that area and then practice those skills
and activities repeatedly until you
achieve the same results
here's the rule if you do what other
successful people do over and over again
nothing can stop you from eventually
enjoying the same rewards that they do
but if you don't do what successful
people do
nothing can help you
the law of sowing and reaping from the
old testament is a variation of the law
of cause and effect
it says that
whatsoever a man soweth that also shall
he reap
this law says that whatever you put in
you get out
it also says that whatever you are
reaping today is a result of what you
have sown in the past
so if you're not happy with your current
crop it's up to you starting today to
plant a new crop to begin doing more of
those things that lead to success and to
stop engaging in those activities that
lead nowhere
success is predictable
success is not an accident sadly failure
is not an accident either
you succeed when you do what other
successful people do over and over until
these behaviors become a habit
likewise you fail if you don't do what
successful people do
in either case nature is neutral
nature does not take sides
nature doesn't care
what happens to you is simply a matter
of law the law of cause and effect
you can look at yourself as a machine
with a default mechanism
your default mechanism is the almost
irresistible attraction of the
expediency factor and the path of least
resistance that i described in the
introduction
in the absence of self-discipline your
default mechanism goes off automatically
this is the main cause of
underachievement and the failure to
realize your true potential
when you are not working deliberately
consciously and continuously to do be
and have those things that constitute
success for you
your default mechanism is at work you
end up doing those fun easy and low
value things in the short term that lead
to frustration financial worries and
failure in the long term
the great oil man h.l hunt who was at
one time the richest self-made
billionaire in the world
was once asked by a television
journalist for his secrets of success
he replied there are only three
requirements for success
first decide exactly what it is you want
in life
second determine the price that you're
going to have to pay to get the things
you want and third and this is most
important
resolve to pay that price
one of the most important requirements
for success once you have decided what
it is that you want is the quality of
willingness
successful people are willing to pay the
price
whatever it is and for as long as it
takes until they achieve the results
they desire
everyone wants to be successful
everyone wants to be healthy happy thin
and rich
but most people are not willing to pay
the price
occasionally they may be willing to pay
part of the price but they're not
willing to pay the whole price they
always hold back they always have some
excuse or rationalization for not
disciplining themselves to do everything
that they need to do to achieve their
goals
pay the price
how can you tell when you have paid the
full price of success
it's simple look around you
there it is
you can always tell how much of the
price of success you have paid by
looking at your current lifestyle and
your bank account
by the law of correspondence your outer
world will like a mirror always reflect
the person you are
and the price that you have paid on the
inside
there's an interesting point about the
price of success it must always be paid
in full
and in advance
success however you define it is not
like a restaurant where you pay after
you've enjoyed your meal
instead it's like a cafeteria where you
can choose whatever you want but you
must pay for it before you eat it
motivational speaker zig ziglar says the
elevator to success is out of order but
the stairs are always open
learn from the experts
cop copmeyer who i mentioned in the
introduction also told me that the
second most important success principle
after self-discipline is that you must
learn from the experts
he said you will never live long enough
to learn it all for yourself
if you want to be successful your first
job is to learn what you need to learn
in order to achieve the success you
desire
learn from the experts read their books
listen to their audio programs attend
their seminars
write to them or approach them directly
and ask for advice
sometimes one idea is all you need to
change the direction of your life
let me give you an example of what i
mean
some years ago i was referred by a
friend to an excellent dentist
i learned later that he had a superb
reputation
he was called the dentist's dentist
he was the dentist that the other
dentist went to when they needed
excellent dental work he told me that he
attended every major dental conference
that he could
when he was there he attended every
session listening to dentists from all
over the country and all over the world
discuss the latest breakthroughs in
dental technology
one week at great sacrifice and time and
money he attended an international
dental conference in hong kong at that
conference he sat in on a session given
by a japanese dentist who discovered a
new technology in cosmetic surgery that
improved the appearance of teeth and
enabled people to look handsome or
beautiful indefinitely
he returned to san diego and immediately
began using the new technique in his
practice
soon he became excellent in this area
and developed a national reputation
within a couple of years people were
coming to him from all over southwestern
united states for this treatment
because he had developed this expertise
he could raise his fees again and again
eventually he had made so much money
that he was able to retire at the age of
55
financially independent and able to
spend the rest of his life with his
family traveling and fulfilling his
dreams
the point of this story is that by
continually seeking out ideas and advice
from other experts in his field
he came across a new technology that
helped him become the leader in his
field and saved him 10 years of hard
work in order to achieve the same level
of financial success
this could happen to you as well
but only if you become a lifelong
student of your craft
mental and physical fitness need to be
ongoing
achieving success is like achieving
physical fitness it is like bathing
brushing your teeth and eating it is
something that you need to do
continuously every day
once you begin you never stop until your
life and career are over and you've
achieved all the success you desire
not long ago i was giving a seminar in
seattle
just before the break i encouraged
people to buy and listen to my audio
programs on sales time management and
personal success
at the break several people came up to
me to ask me questions about the seminar
content
one salesman pushed his way forward and
said loudly
when you encourage people to buy your
programs you should tell them the whole
truth
i ask how do you mean
he went on to say
you are not telling the whole truth
about your programs
you should tell people that they only
work for a certain period of time
and then they stop working
again i asked him how do you mean
he said well i came to your seminar
about five years ago and i was
completely convinced by your
presentation i bought all your programs
and began listening to them i read every
day in sales and you were right over the
next three years i tripled my income and
became the top seller in my company
but then
my income flattened out and has not
increased at all over the last two years
the fact is that your materials stop
working after a certain point
i then asked him in front of all these
other people
what happened to you two years ago when
your income flattened out and stopped
increasing
he searched his memory thought for a
while and said well i was selling so
much that i was hired away by another
company
ever since i started my new job my
income has remained flat
i asked him what did you do differently
in your new job in comparison with your
previous job
he started to answer and then he stopped
a shocked look came over his face
finally he replied oh my gosh i stopped
doing it
when i changed jobs i stopped reading in
sales i stopped listening to audio
programs i stopped attending seminars
i stopped doing it
he walked away shaking his head
muttering to himself
i stopped doing it i stopped doing it i
stopped doing it
becoming an expert in your field
continually upgrading your skills which
i will talk about in chapter five is
like physical fitness
if you stop exercising for any period of
time you don't maintain your fitness at
the same level you begin to decline
your body and your muscles become softer
and weaker you lose your strength
flexibility and stamina
in order to maintain them you must keep
working at them every day every week and
every month
become all you can be
there's an even more important reason
for you to practice the self-discipline
that leads onward and upward to the
great successes that are possible for
you
the practice of self-discipline enables
you to change your character to become a
stronger and better person
the exercise of self-discipline has a
powerful effect on your mind and
emotions developing you into a different
person from the one that you would have
been without self-discipline
imagine yourself in a chemistry lab
you mix a series of chemicals in a petri
dish and put it over a bunsen burner
the bunsen burner heats the chemicals to
the point at which they crystallize and
become hardened but once you crystallize
these chemicals using intense heat they
cannot be transformed back into liquid
form
in the same way your personality begins
like a liquid soft fluid and formless
but as you apply the heat of
self-discipline
as you exert yourself to do what is hard
and necessary rather than what is fun
and easy your personality crystallizes
and hardens at a higher level as well
the greatest benefit you enjoy from
exerting self-discipline in the pursuit
of your goals
is that you become a different person
you become stronger and more resolute
you develop greater self-control and
determination
you actually shape and strengthen your
personality and transform yourself into
a better person
the rule is that to become someone that
you have never been before you must do
something that you have never done
before
this means that to develop a superior
character you must exert ever higher
levels of self-discipline and
self-mastery on yourself
you must do the things that average
people don't like to do
another success principle is that
to achieve something that you've never
achieved before
you must learn and practice qualities
and skills that you've never had before
by practicing self-discipline you become
a new person you become better stronger
and more clearly defined
you develop higher levels of self-esteem
self-respect and personal pride
you move yourself up the ladder of human
evolution and become a person of higher
character and resolve
success is its own reward
the wonderful thing about the
achievement of success is that every
step in that direction is rewarding in
itself
each step you take toward becoming a
better person and accomplishing more
than you ever have before makes you feel
happier more confident and more
fulfilled
you've heard it said that nothing
succeeds like success
what this means is that the greatest
reward of success is not the money you
make but rather the excellent person you
become in the process of striving
towards success and exerting
self-discipline every time it's required
in the next chapter i will explain to
you how you can become the truly
excellent person you are capable of
becoming
now here are some action exercises
take out a pen right now and write down
your answers to the questions below
one
if your work life and career were ideal
what would they look like
what one discipline could you develop
but help you to achieve it
two if your family life were ideal what
would it look like and what one
discipline would help you the very most
to make it a reality
three if your health were perfect in
every way
what discipline would you have that
would make that possible
four if your financial situation were
ideal today what one discipline would
you have that would help you the most
five why aren't you already as
successful as you would like to be
and what one discipline would help you
the most to achieve all your goals
six
what one skill could you develop that
would help you to realize more of your
goals
and seven
if you could wave a magic wand and be
completely disciplined in any one area
which one discipline would have the
greatest positive impact on your life
chapter 2 self-discipline and character
henry ward beecher wrote
hold yourself responsible for a higher
standard than anyone else expects of you
never excuse yourself never pity
yourself
be a hard master to yourself
and be lenient to everyone else
the development of character is the
great business of life
your ability to develop a reputation as
a person of character and honor is the
highest achievement of both social and
business life
ralph waldo emerson wrote what you do
speaks so loudly that i cannot hear a
word you say
the person you are today your innermost
character is the sum total of all your
choices and decisions in life up to this
date
each time you have chosen rightly and
acted consistently with the very best
that you know
you have strengthened your character and
become a better person
the reverse is also true
each time you have compromised taken the
easy way
or behaved in a manner inconsistent with
what you knew to be right you have
weakened your character and softened
your personality
the great virtues
there are a series of virtues or values
that are usually possessed by a person
of character
these are courage compassion
generosity temperance persistence and
friendliness among others we'll talk
about some of these in part three of
this book
coming before all these values however
is the most important one of all when
determining the depth and strength of
your character
integrity
it is your level of integrity living in
complete truth with yourself and others
that demonstrates more than anything
else the quality of your character
in a way integrity is actually the value
that guarantees all the other values
when your level of integrity is higher
you are more honest with yourself and
more likely to live consistently with
all the other values that you admire and
respect
however it takes tremendous
self-discipline to become a person of
character
it takes considerable willpower to
always do the right thing in every
situation and it takes both
self-discipline and willpower to resist
the temptation to cut corners to take
the easy way
or to act for short-term advantage
all of life is a test to see what you
are really made of deep down inside
wisdom can be developed in private
through study and reflection but
character can only be developed in the
give and take of daily life
when you are forced to choose and decide
among alternatives and temptations
the test of character
it is only when you are under pressure
when you are forced to choose one way or
another to either live consistently with
a value or to compromise it that you
demonstrate your true character
emerson also said
guard your integrity as a sacred thing
nothing at last is sacred except the
integrity of your own mind
you are a choosing organism you are
constantly making choices one way or the
other
every choice you make is a statement
about your true values and priorities
at each moment you choose what is more
important or of higher value to you over
what is less important or of lesser
value
the only bulwark against temptation the
path of least resistance and the
expediency factor is character
the only way you can develop your full
character is by exerting your willpower
in every situation when you are tempted
to do what is easy and expedient rather
than what is correct and necessary
the big payoff
the payoff for becoming a person of
character for exercising your willpower
and self-discipline to live consistently
with the very best that you know is
tremendous
when you choose the higher value over
the lower the more difficult over the
easy the right over the wrong
you feel good about yourself
your self-esteem increases you like and
respect yourself more you have a greater
sense of personal pride
in addition to feeling excellent about
yourself when you behave with character
you also earn the respect and esteem of
all the people around you
they will look up to you and admire you
doors will be open for you people will
help you you'll be paid more promoted
faster and given even greater
responsibilities
as you become a person of honor and
character opportunities will appear all
around you
on the other hand you can have all the
intelligence talent and ability in the
world but if people do not trust you you
will never get ahead
people will not hire you and if they do
they will de-hire you as soon as
possible
financial institutions will not lend you
money
because birds of a feather flock
together
the only associates never friends you
will ever have will be other people of
questionable character
furthermore since the people you
associate with have a major effect on
your attitude and personality you make
or break your entire life with the
quality of your character
or the lack thereof
the development of character
aristotle wrote all advancement in
society begins with the development of
the character of the young
this means that advancement in your life
begins with the learning and practice of
values
you learn values in one or all of three
ways instruction
study and practice
let's look at each of these more closely
your children values
one of the chief roles of parenting is
to teach children values this requires
patient instruction and explaining
values to them over and over again as
they are growing up
once is never enough the value and the
importance of living by that value must
be explained
parents must not only give illustrations
but also contrast the adherence to a
value especially that of telling the
truth with its opposite that of lying or
telling half truths
children are very susceptible to the
lessons they receive from the important
people in their lives as they are
growing up
they accept what you say as their parent
as a fact as absolute truth
they absorb what you say like a sponge
you write your description of values on
their souls which are like wet clay
so that what you write becomes a
permanent part of the way they see the
world and relate to life
more than anything else as we'll see in
chapter 19 you demonstrate your values
in your behavior
your children watch you and strive to
emulate the values that you not only
teach and preach but also practice
and they are always watching
the rockefeller family children were
famous for being taught financial values
at an early age
even though their father was one of the
richest men in america the children were
giving tasks and chores to perform
before they received their allowances
they were then instructed on how to
spend their allowances how to save how
much to give to charity and how much to
invest
as a result they grew up to become
successful businessmen and statesmen
unlike children who had grown up in
wealthy homes who were seldom
disciplined in money matters
study the values you admire
you learn values by studying them
closely
the law of concentration says that
whatever you dwell upon grows and
increases in your life
what this means is that when you study
and read stories about men and women who
demonstrated the kind of values that you
admire and respect and then think about
those stories and that behavior
those values sink ever deeper into your
mind
once these values are programmed into
your subconscious they create a
propensity within you to behave
consistently with those values when the
situation requires them
for example in military training
soldiers are continually told stories of
courage obedience discipline and the
importance of supporting their fellow
soldiers
the more they hear these stories discuss
them and think about them the more
likely they are to behave consistently
with these values when they're under the
pressure of actual combat
the core value or virtue of character is
truth
whenever you tell the truth however
inconvenient it may be at the time you
feel better about yourself and you earn
the respect of the people around you
one of the highest accolades you can pay
another person is to say that he or she
always tells the truth
emulate the people you most admire
much of your character is determined by
the people you most admire both living
and dead
who are they
looking over your life and history
make a list of the people whom you most
admire and next to their names write out
the virtues or values that they most
represent to you
if you could spend an afternoon with
anyone living or dead
what one person would you choose
why would you choose that person
what would you talk about during your
afternoon together
what questions would you ask and what
would you want to learn
consider this as well
why would that person want to spend an
afternoon with you
what are the virtues and values that you
have developed that make you a valuable
and interesting person
what makes you special
practice the values you respect
you develop values by practicing them
whenever they are called for
as the roman stoic philosopher epictetus
said
circumstances do not make the man they
merely reveal him to himself
when a problem occurs people tend to
react automatically based on the highest
values that they have developed up to
that moment
we develop values by repetition by
behaving consistently with a particular
value over and over again until it
becomes a habit
and locks in so that we come to practice
it automatically
men and women with highly developed
characters behave in a manner consistent
with their highest values and they do so
without thought or hesitation
there's no question in their minds about
whether or not they're doing the right
thing
the structure of personality
the psychology of character involves the
three parts of your personality
yourself ideal your self-image and your
self-esteem
your self-ideal is that part of your
mind composed of your values virtues
ideals goals aspirations and your idea
of the very best person that you could
possibly be
in other words your self-ideal is
composed of those values that you most
admire in others and most aspire to
possess in yourself
the most important part of yourself
ideal is summarized in the word clarity
superior people are those who are
absolutely clear about who they are and
what they believe
they have complete clarity about the
values they believe in and what they
stand for
they are not confused or indecisive
they are firm and resolute when it comes
to any decision in which a value is
involved
on the other hand weak and irresolute
people are fuzzy and unclear about their
values they have only a vague notion of
what is right or wrong in any situation
as a result they take the path of least
resistance and act expediently
they do whatever seems to be the fastest
and easiest thing to get what they want
in the short term giving little or no
consideration or concern about the
consequences of their acts
the evolution of character
in biology life forms are categorized
from the least to the most complex
from single-celled plankton all the way
up to the increasingly complex spectrum
of life to the human being
similarly human beings can be organized
along a spectrum as well from the least
to the most developed
the lowest forms of humans are those
with no values virtues or character
these people always act expediently and
take the path of least resistance in
their search for immediate gratification
at the highest levels of development of
the human race however
are those men and women of complete
integrity who would never compromise
their honesty or their character for
anything
including the threat of financial loss
pain or even death
george washington is famous for his
honesty which was demonstrated in the
story in which he admitted that he had
cut down the cherry tree
in the same vein the founding fathers of
the united states wrote that we hereby
pledge our lives our fortunes and our
sacred honor to the signing of the
declaration of independence
in his book trust the social virtues and
the creation of prosperity philosopher
francis fukuyama observed that societies
worldwide can be divided into two kinds
high trust and low trust
he also argues that the highest trust
societies those in which integrity is
most admired encouraged and respected
are also the most law-abiding free and
prosperous
at the other end of the societal
spectrum however are those societies
characterized by tyranny thievery
dishonesty and corruption
each of these are without exception both
undemocratic and poor
trust is the key
trust is the lubricant of human
relationships where there is high trust
among and between people economic
activity flourishes and there are
opportunities for all
on the other hand where there is low
trust economic resources are squandered
in an attempt to protect against
thievery and corruption or
those resources are not available at all
in the united states we have the
constitution and bill of rights
these documents lay out the rules by
which americans agree to live they
create the structure of our government
and guarantee our rights
but they assume that our elected
representatives will be men and women of
honor
committed to protecting and defending
those rights they attempt to assure that
only men and women of character can
thrive and prosper over the long term
in our economic political and social
system
they aim to assure that in most cases
only men and women of character can rise
to high positions in society
although our system is not perfect and
people of questionable character
occasionally rise to positions of
prominence it is seldom for very long
the basic demand of americans for
honesty and integrity
eventually leads to the exposure and
censure of dishonest people
the demand for men and women of
character continues unabated
your self-image your inner mirror
the second part of your personality is
your self-image this is the way we see
and think about ourselves especially
prior to any event of importance
people always tend to behave on the
outside consistently with way they see
themselves on the inside
this is often called our inner mirror
into which we appear before we engage in
any behavior
when you see yourself as calm positive
truthful and possessed of high character
you behave with greater strength and
personal power other people respect you
more
you feel in control of yourself and the
situation
what's more whenever you actually behave
in a manner that is consistent with your
highest values your self-image improves
you see and think about yourself in a
better light
you feel happier and more confident your
behavior and outward performance then
reflects this increasingly improving
inner picture you have of yourself as
the very best person you can possibly be
people tend to accept you at your own
evaluation of yourself at least
initially
if you see and think of yourself as an
excellent person who is possessed of
high character you will treat other
people with courtesy grace and respect
in turn they will likewise treat you as
a person of honor and character
your self-esteem
how much you like yourself
the third part of your personality is
your self-esteem
this is how you feel about yourself your
emotional core
your self-esteem is defined as how much
you like yourself
but it's more than only this
the more you see yourself as a valuable
and important person the more positive
and optimistic you will be
when you truly consider yourself to be
important and valuable you will treat
other people as if they are important as
well
your self-esteem is largely determined
by how consistent your self-image which
shapes your personal behavior is with
your self-ideal or your vision of the
very best person you can possibly be
whenever you act consistently with who
you consider an excellent person to be
your self-image improves and your
self-esteem increases
you like and respect yourself more you
feel happy about yourself and others
the more you like yourself the more you
like others and the more they like you
in return
by acting with character and in harmony
with your highest values
you put your whole life
internally and externally into an upward
spiral
in every area of your life things will
get better and better for you
your role models have a tremendous
impact on shaping your character
the more you admire a person and his or
her qualities the more you strive both
consciously and unconsciously to become
like that person
this is why clarity is so important
always behave consistently
whenever you act in a way that is
consistent with your values you feel
good about yourself
whenever you compromise your values for
any reason you feel bad about yourself
this also means that when you compromise
your values your self-confidence and
self-esteem go down
you feel uneasy and inferior
inadequate and uncomfortable
when you compromise your values deep
down inside you feel that something is
fundamentally wrong
almost all human problems can be solved
by a return to your highest values and
your innermost convictions
when you look back there have probably
been situations in your life when you
have compromised your values in order to
save an investment keep a job preserve a
relationship or maintain a friendship
in each case
you have felt worse and worse until you
finally broke it off and walked away
and how did you feel when you finally
had the strength of character to walk
away
you felt wonderful
whenever you use your willpower and
strength of character to return to the
values that are most dear to you
you are rewarded with a wonderful
feeling of happiness and acceleration
you feel energized and free
you wonder why you didn't make that
decision
a long time ago
do the right thing
in the development of character that is
based on self-discipline and willpower
long-term thinking is essential
the more you think about the long-term
consequences of your behavior the more
likely it is that you will do the right
thing in the short term
so when you have to make a choice or
decision
always ask the magic question
what's important here
practice the universal maxim of immanuel
kant the philosopher
he said
resolve to behave as though your every
act were to become a universal law for
all people
one of the great questions for the
development of character is this
what kind of a world would this world be
if everyone in it was just like me
whenever you slip whenever you do or say
something that is inconsistent with your
highest values
immediately get back on your horse
say to yourself this is not like me and
resolve that next time you'll do better
what you dwell upon grows
if you are in a situation today in which
you are not living up to your highest
values
make a decision this very minute to
confront the situation and straighten it
out
the minute you do you will once again
feel happy and back in control
there's an old indian story
on my shoulders are two wolves
one is a black wolf evil who continually
tempts me to do and say the wrong things
on my other shoulder is a white wolf
that continually encourages me to live
up to my very best
a listener asked the old man
which of these wolves has the greatest
power over you
the old man replied
the one i feed
by the law of concentration whatever you
dwell upon grows and increases in your
life
when you think and talk about the
virtues and values that you most admire
and respect
you therefore program those values
deeper and deeper into your subconscious
until they begin to operate
automatically in every situation
whenever you exercise your
self-discipline and willpower to live
your life consistently with those values
that you most aspire to be known for you
begin to move rapidly along the path to
becoming an excellent person
now here are some action exercises for
you
take out a sheet of paper and write out
your answers to these questions
one
name three people living or dead who you
most admire and describe one quality of
each of them that you respect
two
determine the most important virtue or
quality in your life that you strive the
most to practice or emulate
three
identify those situations in which you
feel the most confident in which you
feel like the very best person you could
possibly be
four
what situations give you your greatest
feelings of self-esteem and personal
worth
five if you are already an excellent
person in every respect how would you
behave differently from today onward
six
what one quality would you like people
to think of when your name is mentioned
and what could you do to ensure this
happens
seven
in what one area do you need to be more
truthful and practice higher levels of
integrity than you do today
whatever your answers write them down
and then begin to practice them
chapter 3
self-discipline and responsibility
j paul getty said
the individual who wants to reach the
top in business must appreciate the
might and force of habit
he must be quick to break those habits
that can break him
and hasten to adopt those practices that
will become the habits that help him
achieve the success he desires
your ability and willingness to
discipline yourself to accept personal
responsibility for your life is
essential to happiness health success
achievement and personal leadership
accepting responsibility is one of the
hardest of all disciplines but without
it no success is possible
the failure to accept responsibility and
the attempt of voiced responsibility for
things in your life that make you
unhappy onto other people institutions
and situations
completely distorts cause and effect
undermines your character weakens your
resolve and diminishes your humanity
it leads to making endless excuses
my great revelation
when i was 21 i was living in a tiny
apartment and working as a construction
laborer
i had to get up at 5 00 a.m so that i
could take three buses to work in order
to be there by 8 am
i didn't get home until 7 pm tired out
from carrying construction materials all
day
i was making just enough money to get by
and i had no car almost no savings and
just enough clothes for my needs i had
no radio or television
it was in the middle of a cold winter
with the temperature at
35 degrees fahrenheit so i seldom went
out in the evening
instead if i had enough energy i sat in
my small apartment at my little table in
my kitchen nook and red
one evening late at night as i was
sitting there by myself at the table it
suddenly dawned on me that this is my
life
this life was not a rehearsal for
something else the game was on and i was
the main character as in a play
it was like a flash bulb going off in my
face
i looked at myself and around me at my
small apartment
and i considered the fact that i had not
graduated from high school
the only work that i was qualified to do
was manual labor
i earned just enough money to pay my
basic expenses and i had very little
left over at the end of the month
i suddenly knew that unless i changed
nothing else was going to change
no one else was going to do it for me
in reality no one else really cared
i realized at that moment that from that
day forward i was completely responsible
for my life and for everything that
happened to me
i was responsible
i could no longer blame my situation on
my difficult childhood or mistakes i had
made in the past
i was in charge i was in the driver's
seat
this was my life and if i didn't do
something to change it it would go on
like this indefinitely by the simple
force of inertia
revelation changed my life i was never
the same again from that moment on i
accepted more and more responsibility
for everything in my life
i accepted responsibility for doing my
job better than before
rather than doing only the minimum that
was necessary to avoid getting fired
i accepted responsibility for my
finances my health and especially my
future
the very next day i went down to a local
bookstore at my lunch break and began
the lifelong practice of buying books
with information ideas and lessons that
could help me
i dedicated my life to self-improvement
to continuous learning in every way
possible
for the rest of my business life right
up to the present moment whenever i've
wanted or needed to learn something to
help me i have returned to learning
through reading to listening to audio
programs and attending courses and
seminars
i found that you could learn anything
you need to learn in order to accomplish
any goal you set for yourself
over time i learned that fully eighty
percent of the population never accepts
complete responsibility for their lives
they continually complain criticize make
excuses and
blame other people for things in their
lives about which they're not happy
the consequences of this way of thinking
however can be disastrous
they can sabotage all hopes for success
and happiness later in life
from childhood to maturity
when you are growing up from an early
age you become conditioned to see
yourself as not responsible for your
life
this is normal and natural
when you're a child your parents are in
charge they make all your decisions they
decide what food you will eat what
clothes you will wear what toys you will
play with what home you will live in
what school you will attend and what
activities you'll engage in during your
spare time
because you are young innocent and
unknowing you do what they want you to
do
you have little choice or control
as you grow up however you begin to make
more and more of your own decisions in
each of these areas
but because of your early programming
you are conditioned unconsciously to
feel that someone else is still
responsible for your life that there's
still someone else out there who can or
should take care of you
most people grow up believing that if
something goes wrong someone else is
responsible
someone else is to blame
someone else is guilty
someone else is the villain and they are
the victim
as a result most people make more and
more excuses for the things in their
lives past and present that make them
unhappy
get over the mistakes your parents made
if your parents criticized you or got
angry with you for mistakes you made
when you were growing up
you began to unconsciously assume that
somehow you were at fault
if your parents punished you physically
or emotionally for doing or not doing
something that pleased or displeased
them
you felt inferior and inadequate
when your parents withheld their love to
punish you for not doing something they
demanded you might have grown up with
deep feelings of guilt unworthiness and
undeservingness
all these negative feelings could then
intersect to make you feel like a victim
like you are not responsible for
yourself or your life once you became an
adult
the most common feeling that we have as
adults if we have been raised in a
critical home environment is the feeling
that
i'm not good enough
because of this feeling we compare
ourselves unfavorably to others
we think that other people who seem to
be happier or more confident are better
than us
we develop feelings of inferiority
this can become an emotional trap
the fatal fallacy
if we think for any reason that others
are better than us we unconsciously
assume that we must be worse than they
are
if they are worth more than we are we
assume that we must be worth less
this feeling of inadequacy or
worthlessness lies at the root of most
personality problems in our lives
as well as most political and social
problems in our world both nationally
and
internationally to escape from these
feelings of guilt and worthlessness that
have been instilled in us as the result
of destructive criticism in childhood we
lash out at our world other people and
situations
in any part of our life with which we
are unhappy or discontented our first
reaction is to look around and ask
who's to blame
most religions teach the concept of sin
which states that whenever something
goes wrong someone is to blame
someone has done something bad someone
is guilty
someone must be punished
this whole idea of guilt and punishment
leads to ever increasing feelings of
anger resentment and irresponsibility
an attitude of irresponsibility
our courts today are clogged with
thousands of people demanding redress
and payment for something that went
wrong in their lives
backed up by ambitious plaintiff lawyers
people go to court demanding
compensation
even if they themselves are completely
at fault for what happened especially if
they are at fault
people don't want to accept
responsibility people spill hot coffee
on themselves and sue the fast food
restaurant that sold them the coffee in
the first place
people get drunk and drive off the road
and then turn around and sue the
manufacturer of the 15 year old car they
were driving
people climb up on a stepladder and lean
over too far falling to the ground they
then sue the ladder manufacturer for
their injury
in each case people are attempting to
escape responsibility for their own
behaviors by blaming someone else making
excuses and then demanding
compensation eliminating negative
emotions
the common denominator of all people is
the desire to be happy
in its simplest terms happiness arises
from the absence of negative emotions
where there are no negative emotions all
that is left is positive emotions
therefore the elimination of negative
emotions is your great business in life
if you truly wish to be happy
there are dozens of negative emotions
although the most common are guilt
resentment envy jealousy fear and
hostility
they all ultimately boil down to a
feeling of anger
directed either inward or outward
anger is directed inwardly when you
bottle it up rather than expressing it
constructively to others
anger is directed outwardly when you
criticize or attack other people
psychosomatic illness
negative emotions are the major causes
of psychosomatic illness
this occurs when the mind psycho makes
the body soma sick
negative emotions especially as
expressed in the form of anger
weaken your immune system and make you
susceptible to colds flu and other
diseases
uncontrolled bursts of anger can
actually bring about heart attacks
strokes and nervous breakdowns
here's the great discovery
all negative emotions especially anger
depend for their very existence on your
ability to blame someone or something
else for something in your life that
you're not happy about
it takes tremendous self-discipline to
refrain from blaming others for our
problems
it takes enormous self-control to refuse
to make excuses
it takes tremendous self-discipline for
you to accept complete responsibility
for everything you are
everything you become and everything
that happens to you
even if you are not directly responsible
for something that happens like
hurricane katrina you are responsible
for your responses for what you do and
say from that moment forward
it takes tremendous self mastery for you
to take complete control of your
conscious mind and deliberately choose
to think positive constructive thoughts
that enhance your life and improve the
quality of your relationships and
results
but
the payoff of this form of positive
thinking is
tremendous blaming is easy
by following the path of least
resistance the easiest and most mindless
behavior of all
is for a person to lash out and blame
someone else
anytime anything goes wrong for any
reason people who develop the habit of
automatically blaming often become angry
at things
blaming inanimate objects when they do
not function as expected is so silly
that it almost becomes a mild form of
insanity
people become angry at doors that stick
they swear at tools that they're using
when they themselves make a mistake
they get mad when their car doesn't
start
even if it is an inanimate object if it
doesn't work perfectly then the thing
must be to blame
people will often kick a car that they
are mad at or a box that they tripped
over
the antidote to negative emotions
the fastest and most dependable way to
eliminate negative emotions is to
immediately say i am responsible
whenever something happens that triggers
anger or a negative reaction of any kind
quickly neutralize the feelings of
negativity by saying
i am responsible
the law of substitution says that you
can substitute a positive thought for a
negative one
since your mind can only hold one
thought at a time
when you deliberately choose the
positive thought i am responsible you
cancel out any other thought or emotion
at that moment
it is not possible to accept
responsibility and remain angry at the
same time
it's not possible to accept
responsibility and experience negative
emotions
it's not possible to accept
responsibility without becoming calm
clear positive and focused once more
as long as you are blaming someone else
for something in your life that you
don't like
you will remain a mental child
you continue to see yourself as small
and helpless like a victim
you continue to lash out however when
you begin to accept responsibility for
everything that happens to you you
transform yourself into a mental adult
you will see yourself as being in charge
of your own life and no longer a victim
in alcoholics anonymous people who are
having problems with drinking attend
meetings with others going through the
same situation
what they have found is that until the
individual accepts responsibility for
his or her problems both with alcohol
and in other areas of life
no progress is possible
but after the person accepts
responsibility everything is possible
this is true with almost every difficult
situation in life in which you project
your unhappiness onto other people or
factors outside yourself
money and emotions
many of our biggest problems and
concerns in life have to do with money
earning it spending it investing it and
especially losing it
as a result many of our negative
emotions are associated with money in
some way
however the fact is that you are
responsible for your financial life you
choose you decide you're in charge
you cannot blame your financial problems
or situation on other people you are in
the driver's seat
so it is only when you accept
responsibility for your income
who chose to accept the job you are
working at your bills
who spent the money that put you into
debt
and your investments who made those
decisions
can you move from becoming an economic
child
to an economic adult
responsibility and control
there's a direct relationship between
the acceptance of responsibility and the
amount of personal control you feel you
have over your life
this means that the more you accept
responsibility the greater sense of
control you experience
there's also a direct relationship
between the amount of control you feel
you have and how positive you feel
the more you feel that you have a high
sense of control in the important areas
of your life the more positive and happy
you are in everything you do
when you accept responsibility you feel
strong powerful and purposeful accepting
responsibility eliminates the negative
emotions that rob you of happiness and
contentment
in every situation the antidote to
negative emotions is to say
i am responsible
then look into the situation to find the
reasons why you are responsible for what
happened or for what is going on
your intelligence is like a double-edged
sword it can cut in either direction you
can use your intelligence to rationalize
justify and blame other people for
things you're not happy about
or you can use your intelligence to find
reasons why you are responsible for what
happened and then take action to solve
the problem or resolve the situation
you can make excuses or you can make
progress
you choose
even if an accident has occurred such as
your car being damaged in the parking
lot while you're at work
you may not be legally at fault for the
accident but you are still responsible
for your responses for how you behave as
a result of what happened
never complain never explain
the mark of the leader the truly
superior person is that he or she
accepts complete responsibility for the
situation
it's not possible to imagine a true
leader who whines and complains rather
than taking action when problems and
difficulties arise
this sense of responsibility is the mark
of the highly developed personality
you take responsibility for your life by
resolving in advance that you will not
become upset or angry over something
that you cannot affect or change
just as you do not become angry about
the weather you do not become angry over
circumstances and situations over which
you have no control
furthermore you especially do not allow
yourself to be angry and unhappy in the
present because of unhappy experiences
or situations from the past
you say
what cannot be cured must be endured
it's amazing how many people are unhappy
today because of a past event even
something that happened many years ago
each time they think of the negative
experience they become angry or
depressed once more
the good news is that at any time you
can stop thinking about discussing and
rehashing the past you can let it go
and begin thinking instead about your
goals and your unlimited future
as helen keller said
when you turn toward the sunshine the
shadows fall behind you
self-mastery and self-control
any self-discipline self-mastery and
self-control begins with taking
responsibility for your emotions
you take charge of your emotions by
accepting 100 responsibility for
yourself
and for your responses to everything
that happens to you
you refuse to make excuses complain
criticize or blame other people for
anything
instead you say i am responsible and
then you take action of some kind
the only antidote is action
the only real antidote for anger or
worry is purposeful action in the
direction of your goals which is the
subject of the next chapter
before you turn to that however resolve
today to first take complete control of
your thoughts feelings and actions and
then to get so busy working on things
that are important to you that you don't
have time to think about or express
negative emotions to or about anyone for
any reason
when you exert your self-discipline and
willpower in the acceptance of personal
responsibility for your life
you take complete control of your
thoughts and feelings by doing so you
become a much more effective happy and
positive person in everything you do
now here are some action exercises for
you
one
resolve today to accept 100
responsibility for everything you are
and for everything you become
never complain never explain
two
look into your past and select a person
or incident that still makes you unhappy
today
instead of justifying your negative
feelings
look for reasons why you were partially
responsible for what happened
three
select a relationship in your past that
made you unhappy and then give three
reasons why you were responsible for
what occurred
four
select one person in your past with whom
you are still angry and resolve to
forgive that person completely for what
happened
this act will liberate you emotionally
five
accept complete responsibility for your
financial situation and refuse to blame
any financial problems on anyone else
now what steps are you going to take to
resolve that situation
6.
accept complete responsibility for your
family situation with each person
and then take immediate action to
improve your relationships wherever
there may be problems
and number seven
accept one hundred percent
responsibility for your health
resolve today to do or stop doing
whatever is necessary for you to attain
excellent all-around health
chapter 4
self-discipline and goals
jim rohn said
discipline is the bridge between goals
and accomplishment
your ability to discipline yourself to
set clear goals for yourself and then to
work toward them every day will do more
to guarantee your success than any other
single factor you need to have goals to
accomplish worthwhile things in life
you've probably heard it said that you
can't hit a target that you can't see
if you don't know where you're going any
road will get you there
and as wayne gretzky said
you miss every shot you don't take the
very act of taking the time to decide
what you really want in each area of
your life can change your life
completely
the three percent factor
it seems that only three percent of
adults have written goals and plans and
this three percent earn more than all of
the other 97 percent put together
why is this
the simplest answer is that if you have
a clear goal and a plan to achieve it
you therefore have a track to run on
every single day instead of being
sidetracked by distractions and
diversions getting lost or going astray
more and more of your time is focused in
a straight line from where you are to
where you want to go
this is why people with goals accomplish
so much more than people without them
the tragedy is that most people think
that they already have goals
but what they really have are hopes and
wishes
however hope is not a strategy for
success
and a wish has been defined as a goal
with no energy behind it
goals that are not written down and
developed into plans are like bullets
without powder in the cartridge
people with unwritten goals go through
life shooting blanks
because they think they already have
goals they never engage in the hard
disciplined effort of goal setting and
this is the master skill of success
multiply your chances of success
in 2006 usa today reported a study in
which researchers selected a large
number of people
who had made new year's resolutions
they then divided these people into two
categories
those who had set new year's resolutions
and written them down and those who had
set new year's resolutions but had not
written them down
12 months later they followed up on the
respondents in this study and what they
found was astonishing
of the people who had set new year's
resolutions but had not written them
down
only four percent had actually followed
through on their resolutions
but among the group who had written down
their new year's resolutions an exercise
requiring only a couple of minutes
44 had followed through on them
this is a difference of more than 1100
percent in success and it was achieved
by the simple act of crystallizing the
resolutions on paper
the discipline of writing
in my experience working with several
million people over the past 25 years
the disciplined act of writing out goals
making plans for accomplishing them and
then working on those goals daily
increases the likelihood of achieving
your goals by ten times or one thousand
percent
this doesn't mean that writing out your
goals guarantees success but rather only
that it increases the probability of
success by ten times
these are very good odds to have working
in your favor
especially when there is no cost or risk
involved in putting pen to paper
just a little time
writing is called a psychoneuro motor
activity
the act of writing forces you to think
and concentrate it forces you to choose
what is more important to you and your
future
as a result when you write down a goal
you impress it into your subconscious
mind which then goes to work 24 hours a
day to bring your goal to reality
sometimes i tell my seminar audiences
only three percent of adults have
written goals and everyone else works
for those people
in life you either work to achieve your
own goals or you work to achieve the
goals of someone else
which is it going to be
success versus failure mechanisms
your brain has both a success mechanism
and a failure mechanism
the failure mechanism is the temptation
to follow the undisciplined path of
least resistance to
do what is fun and easy rather than what
is hard and necessary your failure
mechanism operates automatically
throughout your life which is the major
reason why most people fail to fulfill
their individual potentials
while your failure mechanism functions
automatically your success mechanism is
triggered by a goal
when you decide on a goal you override
your failure mechanism
and can help you change the direction of
your life
you go from being a ship without a
rudder drifting with the tide to being a
ship with a rudder a compass and a clear
destination
sailing in a straight direction towards
your goal
the power of goals
a client of mine recently told me an
interesting story
he said that he had attended one of my
seminars in 1994 where i spoke about the
importance of writing down goals and
making plans for accomplishing them
at that time he was 35 years old selling
cars for a dealership in nashville and
earning about fifty thousand dollars a
year
he told me that that day changed his
life he began writing out his goals and
plans and working on them daily twelve
years later he was earning more than one
million dollars a year and was the
president of a fast-growing company that
sells services to some of the biggest
companies in the country he told me that
he could not imagine what his life would
have been like if he had not taken out a
piece of paper and written down the
goals he wanted to achieve in the years
ahead
take control of your life
aristotle wrote that human beings are
teleological organisms which simply
means that we are purpose driven
therefore you only feel happy and in
control of your life when you have a
clear goal that you aren't working
toward each day
this also means that this ability to
become a lifelong goal setter is one of
the most important disciplines you will
ever develop
in nature the homing pigeon is a
remarkable bird it has an uncanny
instinct that enables it to fly back to
its home roost no matter how far away it
starts or in what direction it must go
you can take a homing pigeon out of its
roost put it in a cage put the cage in a
box cover the box with a blanket and put
the covered box in the back of a pickup
truck you could then drive one thousand
miles in any direction open up the truck
take out the box take off the blanket
open the cage and throw the homing
pigeon up into the air
the homing pigeon will circle three
times get its bearings and then fly
straight back to its home roost
this is the only creature on earth that
has this ability except for human beings
except for you
you also have this remarkable homing
ability within your own brain
but with one special difference
the homing pigeon seems to know
instinctively exactly where its home
roost is located it then has the ability
to fly directly back to that roost
in contrast when human beings program a
goal into their minds they can then set
out without having any idea where they
will go or how they will achieve that
goal
but by some miracle they will begin to
move unerringly toward that goal and the
goal will begin to move toward them
still many people are hesitant to set
goals
they say i want to be financially
independent but i have no idea how i'm
going to get there
as a result they don't even set
financial success as a goal
but the good news is that you don't need
to know how to get there
you just need to be clear about what you
want to accomplish and the goal striving
mechanism in your brain
will guide you unerringly to your
destination
for example you can decide that you are
going to find your ideal job in which
you work for and with people you like
and respect and do work that is both
challenging enjoyable
you take some time to write down an
exact description of what your ideal job
and workplace would look like and then
you go out into the job market and begin
searching
after a series of interviews you will
often walk into the right place at the
right time and find yourself in exactly
the right job
almost everyone has had this experience
at one time or another
you can have it by design rather than by
chance
simply by developing absolute clarity
about what you really want
the seven-step method to achieving your
goals
there are seven simple steps that you
can follow to set and achieve your goals
faster there are more complex and
detailed goal-achieving methodologies
but this seven-step method will enable
you to accomplish ten times more than
you've ever accomplished before and you
will do so far faster than you can
currently imagine
step one decide exactly what you want
be specific
if you want to increase your income
decide on a specific amount of money
rather than to just make more money
step two write it down
a goal that is not in writing is like
cigarette smoke it drifts away and
disappears it is vague and insubstantial
it has no force effect or power but a
written goal becomes something that you
can see
touch read and modify if necessary
step three set a deadline for your goal
pick a reasonable time period and write
down the date when you want to achieve
it if it's a big enough goal set a final
deadline and then set sub deadlines or
interim steps between where you are
today and where you want to be in the
future
a deadline serves as a forcing system in
your brain
just as you often get more done when
you're under the pressure of a specific
deadline
your subconscious mind works faster and
more efficiently when you have decided
that you want to achieve a goal by a
specific time
the rule is there are no unrealistic
goals there are only unrealistic
deadlines
what do you do if you don't achieve your
goal by your deadline simple you set
another deadline
a deadline is just a guesstimate
sometimes you will achieve your goal
before the deadline sometimes at the
deadlines and sometimes after the
deadline
when you set your goal it will be within
the context of a certain set of external
circumstances but these circumstances
may change causing you to change your
deadline as well be flexible
step number four
make a list of everything that you could
think of that you could possibly do to
achieve your goal
as henry ford said the biggest goal can
be accomplished if you just break it
down into enough small steps
make a list of the obstacles and
difficulties that you will have to
overcome both external and internal in
order to achieve your goal
make a list of the additional knowledge
and skills that you will require in
order to achieve your goal
make a list of the people whose
cooperation and support you will require
to achieve your goal
make a list of everything that you can
think of that you will have to do
and then add to this list as new tasks
and responsibilities occur to you
keep writing until your list is complete
step five
organize your list by both sequence and
priority
a list of activities organized by
sequence requires that you decide what
you need to do first what you need to do
second and what you need to do later on
in addition a list organized by priority
enables you to determine what is more
important and what is less important
sometimes sequence and priority are the
same but often they are not
for example if you want to start a
particular kind of business the first
item in order of sequence might be for
you to purchase a book or enroll in a
course on that business but what is most
important is your ability to develop a
business plan
based on complete market research that
you can use to gather the resources you
need and actually start the business you
have in mind
step six take action on your plan
immediately
take the first step
and then the second step and the third
step
get going get busy move quickly don't
delay
remember procrastination is not only the
thief of time
it's the thief of life
the difference between success and
failures in life is simply that winners
take the first step they are action
oriented
as they said in star trek they go boldly
where no man has ever gone before
winners
are willing to take action with no
guarantees of success
though they're willing to face failure
and disappointment they're always
willing to take action as well
step 7
do something every day that moves you in
the direction of your major goal
this is the key step that will guarantee
your success
do something seven days a week 365 days
a year
do anything that moves you at least one
step closer to the goal that is most
important to you at that time
when you do something every day that
moves you in the direction of your goal
you develop momentum
this momentum this sense of forward
motion motivates inspires and energizes
you
as you develop momentum you'll find it
increasingly easy to take more steps
towards your goal
in no time at all you will have
developed the discipline of setting and
achieving your goals
it will soon become easy and automatic
you will soon develop a habit and the
discipline of working toward your goals
all the time
the 10 goal exercise
this is one of the most powerful goal
achieving methods i have ever discovered
i teach it all over the world and i
practice it myself almost every day
here's how it works
take out a clean sheet of paper
at the top of the page write the word
goals and today's date
then discipline yourself to write down
10 goals that you'd like to accomplish
in the next 12 months
write down financial family goals and
fitness goals as well as goals for
personal possessions like a house or a
car
don't worry for the moment about how
you're going to achieve these goals just
write them down as quickly as you can
you can write as many as 15 goals if you
like but this exercise requires that you
write down a minimum of 10 within 3-5
minutes
select one goal
once you've written out your 10 goals
imagine for the moment that you can
achieve all the goals on your list
if you wanted them long enough and hard
enough
also imagine that you have a magic wand
that you can wave that will enable you
to achieve any one goal on your list
within 24 hours
if you could achieve any one goal on
your list within 24 hours
which one would have the greatest
positive impact on your life right now
which one goal would change or improve
your life more than anything else
which one goal if you were to achieve it
would help you to achieve more of your
other goals than anything else
whatever your answer to this question
put a circle around this goal and then
write it at the top of a clean sheet of
paper
this goal then becomes your major
definite purpose
it becomes your focal point and the
organizing principle of your future
activities
make a plan
once you've written out this goal
clearly and specifically and made it
measurable set a deadline on your goal
your subconscious mind needs a deadline
so that it can focus and concentrate all
your mental powers on goal attainment
make a list of everything that you could
think of that you could do to achieve
your goal
organize this list by sequence and
priority
select the most important or logical
next step in your plan and take action
on it immediately take the first step do
something do anything
resolve to work on this goal every
single day until it's achieved
from this moment forward as far as you
are concerned failure is not an option
once you've decided that this one goal
can have the greatest positive impact on
your life and you've said it as your
major definite purpose
resolve that you will work toward this
goal as hard as you can as long as you
can and that you will never give up
until it's achieved
this decision alone can change your life
use mindstorming to get started
here's another technique that you can
use to dramatically increase the
likelihood that you will achieve your
most important goal
this is the most powerful creative
thinking technique i've ever seen
more people have become wealthy using
this method than any other way
take another clean sheet of paper write
out your major definite purpose your
number one goal at the top of the page
in the form of a question then
discipline yourself to write a minimum
of 20 answers to the question
for example if your goal is to earn a
certain amount of money by a certain
date you would write the question how
can i earn this amount of money by this
specific date
you then discipline yourself to generate
20 answers to your question
this exercise of mindstorming will
activate your mind unleash your
creativity and give you ideas that you
may have never thought of before
the first three to five answers will be
easy
the next five will be difficult and the
last 10 answers will be harder than you
can imagine at least the first time you
do this exercise
nonetheless you must exert your
discipline and willpower to persist
until you have written down at least 20
answers
once you've generated 20 answers look
over your list and select one of those
answers to take action on immediately
it seems that when you take action on a
single idea on your list it triggers
more ideas and motivates you to take
action on even more of these answers
the great law of cause and effect
the most important application of the
law of cause and effect is that thoughts
are causes and conditions are effects
your thoughts create the conditions of
your life
when you change your thinking you change
your life
your outer world becomes a mirror image
reflection of your inner world
perhaps the greatest discovery in the
history of thought is that
you become what you think about most of
the time
moreover the teacher john boyle said
whatever you can think about on a
continuing basis
you can have
napoleon hill author of the success
classic think and grow rich which was
first published in 1939 and is still
selling today said
whatever the mind of man can conceive
and believe it can achieve
when you think about your goal
continually and work on it every day
more and more of your mental resources
will be concentrated on moving you
toward that goal
and moving your goal toward you
the discipline of daily goal setting
will make you a powerful purposeful and
irresistible person
you'll develop self-esteem
self-confidence and self-respect
as you feel yourself moving toward your
goals faster and faster you will
ultimately become
unstoppable
in the next chapter i'll explain how the
use of self-discipline to develop
personal excellence is the most powerful
step you can take to achieve all your
material and emotional goals
now here are some action exercises for
you
one resolve today to switch on your
success mechanism and unlock your goal
achieving mechanism
by deciding exactly what you really want
in life
two
make a list of 10 goals that you want to
achieve in the foreseeable future
write them down in the present tense as
if you had already achieved them
three
select the one goal that could have the
greatest positive impact on your life if
you were to achieve it and write it down
at the top of another piece of paper
four
make a list of everything that you could
do to achieve this goal organize it by
sequence and priority and then take
action on it immediately
number five
practice mindstorming by writing out 20
ideas that could help you to achieve
your most important goal
and then take action on at least one of
these ideas
six
resolve to do something every day seven
days a week to achieve your most
important goal until you are
successful and number seven continually
remind yourself that failure is not an
option
no matter what resolve to persist until
you succeed
chapter five
self-discipline and personal excellence
aristotle wrote
we are what we repeatedly do
excellence therefore is not an act but a
habit
you are your most valuable asset your
life your potential and your
possibilities are the most precious
things you have
thus your great goal in life should be
to fulfill that potential and become
everything you are capable of becoming
your ability to learn grow and fulfill
your potential is unlimited
today people are graduating from high
school and college in their seventies
learning new subjects and developing new
capabilities
your ability to learn and remember can
continue throughout your life if you
keep your brain alive alert and
functioning at its best
your most precious financial asset is
your earning ability
your ability to work is your primary
source of cash throughout your life
you could lose your home your car your
bank account everything you own but as
long as you have your earning ability
you can earn it all back and more in the
months and years ahead
your biggest investment
most people don't realize this they take
their earning ability for granted but it
has taken you your entire life to
develop your earning ability
every bit of education experience and
hard work that you have invested in
learning your craft and developing your
skills has gone into building this asset
your earning ability is very much like a
muscle it can increase and strengthen
power year by year as a result of
regular exercise
likewise the opposite is true too
if left alone or ignored your earning
ability like your muscles can become
weaker or even decline because you have
simply failed to upgrade it continually
in other words your earning ability can
be either an appreciating or a
depreciating asset
and appreciate an asset is something
that grows in a value and cash flow
every year
as a result of continual investment and
improvement
a depreciating asset on the other hand
is something that loses value over time
and finally reaches the point at which
it is written off being of little or no
further value
the choice is yours as to whether your
earning ability is increasing or
decreasing month by month and year by
year
see yourself as the president of your
own personal services corporation
imagine that you're going to take your
company public on the stock market
would you recommend your company as a
growth stock
continually increasing its value and
earning ability each year
or would you describe your company as
one that has leveled off in the
marketplace that is not really going
anywhere in terms of increased value and
income
would you recommend stock in you inc
as an excellent investment
why or why
not what got you here won't get you any
further
some people are actually losing value
each year declining in earning ability
because they are not continually
upgrading their knowledge and skills
they don't realize that whatever
knowledge and skill they have today is
rapidly becoming obsolete
it's being replaced by new knowledge and
skills that if you don't have them and
someone else does you'll be in danger of
being overtaken by your competition
join the top twenty percent
in chapter one i mentioned that the 80
20 rule applies to income
the top 20 percent of people in our
society earn and control 80 percent of
the assets
according to forbes fortune business
weekend wall street journal and the irs
by many estimates the top one percent of
americans control as much as 33 percent
of the assets
the most interesting discovery in income
inequality is that most millionaires
multi-millionaires and billionaires in
america are first generation
they started with little or nothing and
earned all their money by themselves in
one lifetime
in america there's a high level of
income mobility which means that you are
able to move from the lower levels of
income to the upper levels
almost everyone who is in the top 20
percent today started in the bottom 20
percent
from that point they began to do
something different with their time in
their lives and as a result they put
themselves squarely onto the upward
escalator of financial success
no limits on your potential
the average income increase in america
is about three percent a year
just about the same as the rate of
inflation and cost of living increases
people whose income is increasing at
three percent a year seldom get ahead
they have a job which can also be
thought of as an acronym for just over
broke
but the fact is that no one is better
than you and no one is smarter than you
if someone is doing better than you are
today it is simply proof that they have
learned how the law of cause and effect
applies to their work and they have
begun doing the things that other
successful people have also done
the application of the law of cause and
effect to your personal life is learn
and do
the achievement of personal excellence
is a decision you make or that you fail
to make but in the absence of a
commitment to excellence in your chosen
field you automatically default to
average performance or even mediocrity
no one becomes excellent accidentally or
by just going to work each day
excellence requires a definite decision
and a lifelong commitment
the keys to the 21st century
knowledge and skill are the keys to the
21st century
becoming the best person you can
possibly be and moving to the top of
your field requires the application of
self-discipline throughout your life
mental fitness is like physical fitness
if you want to achieve either you must
work at it all the time you can never
let up you must be continually learning
and growing every day week and month
throughout your career and in other
areas of your life if you're going to
join the top twenty percent and stay
there
to earn more you must learn more
abraham lincoln once wrote the fact that
some have become wealthy is proof that
others may do it as well
what others have done you can do as well
if you learn how
everyone who is at the top was once at
the bottom
many people who come from average or
poor families with average incomes or
who grow up in every circumstances have
gone on to become some of the most
prominent people in their fields
and what hundreds of thousands and even
millions of other people have done you
can do as well
the philosopher bertrand russell once
wrote
the very best proof that something can
be done
is that someone else has already done it
ordinary into extraordinary
very often you see people who don't seem
to be as intelligent or as talented as
you are who are nonetheless
accomplishing remarkable things with
their lives
there's nothing that will make you
angrier than to see someone who seems to
be dumber than you who's doing better
than you
how can this be
the answer is simple at a certain point
in their lives they realize that the key
to success was personal and professional
growth
it was a dedication to lifelong learning
that made them successful
the good news is that almost every
important skill is learnable
every business skill is learnable
everyone who is proficient in any area
of business was at one time completely
ignorant in that area every sales skill
is learnable
every top salesperson was once a
beginning sales person and unable to
make a call or close a sale
all money making skills are learnable as
well
almost every wealthy person was once
poor
you can learn anything you need to learn
to achieve any goal you can set for
yourself
make a decision
the starting point if you're moving
upward and onward toward becoming one of
the most competent most respected and
highest-paid people in your field is
simple make a decision
it's said that every major change in
your life comes about when your mind
collides with a new idea and then you
make a decision to do something
different
you make a decision to complete your
education upgrade your skills or get
into a good college
you make a decision to start a new
business you make a decision to take a
particular job or start a particular
career
you make a decision to invest your money
in a particular way
and especially you make a decision to be
the best in your field
many people say that they would like to
be happy healthy thin and rich
but as discussed in chapter four wishing
and hoping is not enough you have to
make a firm unequivocal decision that
you are going to pay any price and go
any distance in order to achieve the
goals you have set for yourself
you have to make that decision and then
burn your mental bridges behind you
from that moment on you resolve to
continue working on yourself and your
craft
until you reach the top 20 percent or
beyond
follow the leaders not the followers
when you decide to be one of the best
people in your field
look around you and identify the people
who are already at the top
what characteristics do they have in
common
how do they plan and organize their days
how do they dress
how do they walk talk and behave with
other people what books do they read how
do they spend their spare time
who do they associate with
what courses have they taken
what audio programs do they listen to in
their cars
these are just a few of the questions
you should ask in order to find out what
successful people are doing that you
might also need to do
after all
you can't hit a target that you can't
see
your selection of the right role models
can have an enormous impact on your
future
dr david mcclelland of harvard and
author of the achieving society
concluded that your choice of a
reference group can determine as much as
95 percent of your success at
achievement in life
your reference group is made up of the
people who you feel are just like me
your natural tendency is to adopt the
attitudes styles of dress opinions and
lifestyles of the people with whom you
identify and associate most of the time
fly with the eagles
some years ago one of my seminar
participants told me his story
bob barton said he had started off in
his 20s in a large company with about 32
sales people in his branch
it was his first real job and he was
starting at the bottom
because he was new he hung around with
the other junior salespeople
as they say birds of a feather flocked
together
after a month or two bob noticed that
the top sales people in the office also
associated with each other
they did not spend time with the junior
sales people
they also spent their time differently
when bob got into work in the morning
the top sales people were already there
planning their days and working on the
telephone and making appointments
bob also noticed that the junior sales
people would come in later drink coffee
read the newspaper and make excuses for
not making sales calls
bob decided that he was going to pattern
himself after the top sales people in
the office
he looked at the way they dressed and
groomed and he resolved to dress and
groom the way they did
each morning he would stand in front of
his mirror and ask himself do i look
like one of the top salespeople in my
office
if the answer was no he would go back
and change his clothes until he felt
that he looked as good as the best
people
he began to come into the office and
organize his day before 8 30 a.m so that
he was ready to make calls as soon as
his customers were available to see him
one day bob asked one of the top sales
people if he could recommend a book or
audio program that would help him
it turns out that top people are always
willing to help other people improve
when he got the recommendation bob
immediately went out and got the book
and sent away for the audio program
he read the book and listened to the
program and then reported back to the
top salesman the top salesman gave him
some more advice on things to read and
listen to
all of which bob followed
bob asked another salesperson how he
planned his day and that salesperson
showed him his time management system so
bob began to plan and organize his day
the way the top sales people did it
by using these top sales people as his
role models and emulating them whenever
possible
bob started to make more appointments
see more prospects and make more sales
within six months he was one of the top
sales people in the office as well
by that time the top sales people had
invited him for coffee and lunch and he
became one of them rather than one of
the junior people the next year bob went
to the national sales conference where
he met a lot of the top people from
around the country
he deliberately sought them out and
asked for their advice what books would
they suggest what audio programs would
they recommend what seminar said they
attended what strategies did they find
that were the most effective in building
their sales business
bob did something that very few people
do
when he received advice he followed it
he immediately took action on the advice
and then reported back to the people who
had given it to him
within four years bob became one of the
top salespeople in the country his
friends and associates were the other
top salespeople in his branch and in the
other branches
his income had increased several times
he wore beautiful clothes drove a new
car
lived in a lovely home and had a
wonderful wife
and he said that it all came about as a
result of asking top salespeople for
their input and then following that
input and applying it to his sales
activities
but here's the kicker
over and over the top people the ones
who had been winning the sales awards
year after year told bob the same thing
he was the first person who had ever
come up to them and asked them for
advice
no one else had ever sought them out and
asked them why they were so successful
the answers have all been found
here is a great discovery all the
answers have been found
all the roots to success have been
discovered
everything you need to learn to move to
the top of your field has already been
learned by hundreds and even thousands
of other people
and if you ask them for advice they will
give it to you successful people will
have their phone calls held cancel other
appointments and put their work aside to
help other people to be successful but
you must ask and then you must follow
their advice once they give it to you
if you can't ask them directly read
their books and attend their talks and
seminars
listen to audio programs created by
successful people
sometimes you can send them emails and
ask for advice
learn from the best
set high income as a goal
if your goal is to be in the top twenty
percent of money makers in your field
the first thing you need to do is to
find out what the people in the top
twenty percent are earning today
this information is available just ask
around
check industry statistics go on to
google you can find this information if
you look for it
once you know the income target at which
you are aiming write it down as your
goal make a plan to achieve this level
of income and work on it every day
never stop until you reach it
the secret to high income in business
and sales is quite simple
learn and do
like jacking up a car you improve one
notch at a time
each time you learn and practice a new
skill you ratchet up your earning
ability and it locks in
as long as you keep increasing your
earning ability you keep ratcheting up
to a higher level from which you sell
them decline
use the three percent formula to invest
in yourself
to guarantee your lifelong success
make a decision today to invest three
percent of your income back into
yourself
this seems to be the magic number for
lifelong learning
according to the american society for
training and development this is the
percentage that the most profitable 20
percent of companies in every industry
invest in the training and development
of their staff
decide today to invest three percent of
your income into yourself in order to
make yourself an appreciating asset
to continually increase your earning
ability
if your annual income goal is fifty
thousand dollars resolve to invest three
percent of that amount or fifteen
hundred dollars
back into yourself each year to maintain
and upgrade your knowledge and skills
if your income goal is hundred thousand
dollars resolve to invest three thousand
dollars per year back into yourself to
assure that you reach that level of
income
the payoff is extraordinary
i was giving a seminar in detroit a
couple of years ago when a young man
about 30 years old came up to me at the
break he told me that he had first come
to my seminar and heard my three percent
rule about 10 years ago
at that time he had dropped out of
college was living at home driving an
old car and earning about twenty
thousand dollars a year as an office to
office salesman
he decided after the seminar that he was
going to apply the three percent rule to
himself and he did so immediately
he calculated three percent of his
income of twenty thousand dollars would
be six hundred dollars
he began to buy sales books and read
them every day he invested in two audio
learning programs on sales and time
management he took one sales seminar
he invested the entire six hundred
dollars in himself in learning to become
better
that year his income went from twenty
thousand to thirty thousand an increase
of fifty percent
he said he could trace the increase with
great accuracy to the things he had
learned and applied from the books he
had read and the audio programs he had
listened to
so the following year he invested three
percent of thirty thousand dollars a
total of nine hundred dollars back into
himself
that year his income jumped from thirty
thousand dollars to fifty thousand
dollars
he began to think if my income goes up
at fifty percent per year by investing
three percent back into myself
what would happen if i invested five
percent
the next year he invested five percent
of his income twenty five hundred
dollars into his learning program
he took more seminars traveled cross
country to a conference bought more
audio and video learning programs and
even hired a part-time coach
and that year his income doubled to a
hundred thousand dollars
after that like playing texas hold'em he
decided to go all in and raise his
investment into himself to ten percent
per year
he told me that he'd been doing this
ever since
i asked him how is investing 10 percent
of your income back into yourself
affected your income
he smiled and said i passed a million
dollars in personal income last year
and i still invest 10 percent of my
income in myself every single year
i said wow that's a lot of money how do
you manage to spend that much money on
personal development he said it's hard i
have to start spending money on myself
in january in order to invest it all by
the end of the year
i have an image coach a sales coach and
a speaking coach i have a large library
in my home with every book audio program
and video program on sales and personal
success i can find i attend conferences
both nationally and internationally in
my field and my income keeps going up
every year
there are three simple steps to become
the best
becoming one of the top people in your
field requires discipline and
application more than anything else
there are three simple steps that you
can follow to become the very best in
your field
one
read 60 minutes in your field each day
turn off the television and the radio
put aside the newspaper and read
material about your field for one hour
each day before you start working
two listen to educational audio programs
in your car
start them and stop them as you listen
so that you can reflect on what you have
just heard and think about how you can
apply the ideas to your work
three
attend courses and seminars in your
field regularly seek them out take
online courses in the convenience of
your own home courses that enable you to
upgrade your skills and give you
important ideas that you can use to be
even more successful
the power of compound learning like
compound interest is quite amazing
the more you learn the more you can
learn the more you learn the better your
brain functions and the smarter you get
your memory and retention rate improves
the more you learn the more
relationships you find between something
you learned at one time and something
you learn at another time
never stop learning and growing
the achievement of mastery how long does
it take to achieve mastery in your field
according to the experts the acquisition
of mastery requires about seven years or
ten thousand hours of hard work
it takes seven years to become a master
salesperson
it takes seven years to become a
successful business person
it takes seven years to become an
excellent diesel mechanic
it takes seven years to become an
excellent brain surgeon
it seems to take seven years or ten
thousand hours of hard work to get to
the top of any field
so you might as well get started the
time is going to pass
anyway the starting point of your
achieving mastery is for you to commit
to excellence
i've never met a person who made a
decision to get into the top 20 in their
field who did not eventually achieve it
and i never met a person who got there
having not made that decision
making the decision and then following
up with continuous purposeful
disciplined action is essential
talent is not enough
as i mentioned earlier according to
jeffrey colvin in his best-selling book
talent is overrated
most people learn how to do their job in
the first year
and then they never get any better
they just coast in their jobs but the
only direction you can coast is downhill
many people will work away at a job for
many years and never rise above the
average
they will do their job from eight to
five but they never lift a finger to
upgrade their skills they will not
invest any time learning their craft
unless their company pays for the extra
training and gives them the time off to
take it
the average person does only an average
job
and as a result he earns an average
income and worries about money all his
life
he never realizes that often there is
only a thin veil that separates the
average person from the excellent person
the fact is that if you're not getting
better you're getting worse
no one stays in the same place for long
two hours each day will get you to the
top
it's been calculated that all you need
to invest is about two extra hours per
day to move from the average to the
superior
only two extra hours each day will move
you from worrying about money all your
life to being one of the highest paid
people in your field
people immediately ask where am i going
to get an extra two hours each day it's
simple take a piece of paper and do the
following simple calculation
calculate the number of hours in a week
seven days times 24 hours equals 168
hours
if you deduct 40 hours for work and 56
hours for sleep you have 72 hours left
over
if you deduct three hours per day 21
hours for getting ready for and
traveling to and from work that leaves
you 51 hours of spare time to do with as
you please
if you invest 2 hours per day back into
yourself
14 hours per week you still have 37
hours left over
that's an average of more than 5 hours
per day of free time
all you need to do is devote two hours
each day to move you from average
performance to superior performance at
whatever you choose to do
form the habit of continuous learning
the best news is that when you begin
reading in personal or professional
development literature
listening to audio programs in your car
taking additional courses and upgrading
your skills in the evenings and on the
weekends rather than watching television
you soon get into the habit of
continuous learning
in no time at all it will become
automatic and easy for you to learn grow
and upgrade your skills every day and
every week
the average adult watches about five
hours of television each day for some
people it is seven or eight hours
they turn on the television first thing
in the morning and watch it until they
leave for work
they turn it back on as soon as they get
home from work
they then watch television until 11 or
12 o'clock at night going to bed without
enough time to get a good night's sleep
they then get up in the morning drink
coffee and watch television for as long
as they can before they go off to work
once more
you can be rich or poor it's your
decision
your television set can make you rich or
poor if you watch it all the time it
will make you poor
psychologists have shown that the more
television you watch the lower are your
levels of energy and self-esteem
at an unconscious level you don't like
or respect yourself as much if you sit
there hour after hour watching
television
people who watch too much television
also gain weight and become physically
unfit from sitting around too much
your television can also make you rich
but only if you turn it off
when you turn off your television you
free up time you can then use to invest
in becoming a better smarter or more
competent person
when you leave your television off when
you are with your family you'll find
yourself talking sharing communicating
and laughing more often
when you leave your television off for
extended periods of time you break the
habit of watching television and you'll
hardly miss it at all your television
can be an excellent servant but it's a
terrible master
the choice is yours
increase your income one thousand
percent
there is a simple seven step formula you
can use in order to increase your
productivity performance and output and
income by one thousand percent over the
next ten years
it works for everyone who tries it it is
simple
first answer this question
is it possible for you to increase your
overall productivity performance and
output by one tenth of one percent which
is one one thousandth in an entire
working day
your answer will probably be yes if you
were to manage your time a little better
and work on more valuable tasks you
would quite easily increase your output
by one one thousandth in a day
having done this for the first day could
you increase your output by one tenth of
one percent the second day
and the answer of course is yes
having increased your performance by one
tenth of one percent on monday and
tuesday could you continue to do this
for wednesday thursday and friday and
again the answer is yes
one half of one percent per week
one tenth of one percent times five days
per week equals one half of one percent
per week
is it possible for a normal intelligent
hard-working individual to increase his
or her output by one-half of one percent
or one two hundredth in a single week of
course it is
having done this for the first week
could you keep up the same pace of
personal development the second week of
course you could
could you get one one thousandth of one
percent better five days a week for an
entire month
if you could this means that you would
be one half of one percent better per
week
multiplied times four or 2 percent more
productive in an entire month
there are 13 4-week months in a year 4
times 13 equals 52
having become 2 percent better in a
month could you repeat that in the
second month in the third month the
fourth month and so on
of course you could by working on
yourself a little bit each day learning
new skills getting better at your key
tasks setting priorities and focusing on
higher value activities
you can become 26 percent more
productive over the course of an entire
year
having achieved this goal for the first
year could you do it for the second year
and then the third could you keep it up
for 10 years
and the answer of course is yes and the
best news is that when you continue to
work on yourself it becomes easier and
easier for you to get better and better
as the weeks and months go by
by the law of accumulation or the law of
incremental improvement
by the end of twelve months you would be
twenty six percent better
if you continue to improve at twenty six
percent per year by the end of ten years
with compounding you would be one
thousand and four percent more
productive
your income would increase at the same
rate
this formula works if you do
there are seven steps in the one
thousand percent formula
step one
arise two hours before your first
appointment or before you have to be at
work
invest the first hour in yourself by
reading something educational
motivational or spiritual
as henry ward beecher once said
the first hour is the rudder of the day
when you get up and invest the first
hour in yourself you set yourself up
mentally to have an excellent day you'll
be more positive alert creative and
productive all day long when you start
your day by investing the first hour in
yourself
you read in your field one hour per day
that will translate into about one book
per week
one book per week will translate into
about 50 books per year
since the average adult reads less than
one nonfiction book per year
if you were to read 50 books in your
field each year do you think that would
give you an edge in your profession
do you think that it would move you
ahead of virtually everyone else in your
business
of course it would
if you read 50 books per year for 10
years this would be 500 books that would
help you to improve your productivity
performance and income
at the very least you would need a
bigger house just to hold your books and
you'd be able to afford it
reading one hour per day in your field
will make you a national authority in
three to five years
this alone can give you your thousand
percent increase over the course of your
career
step two
rewrite your goals every day get a
spiral notebook and rewrite your major
goals in the present tense every morning
before you start out without looking
back at what you wrote the previous day
this writing and rewriting is the
process of programming instructions into
the guidance mechanism of your mind
when you rewrite your 10 goals each
morning you will continually see and
think of opportunities to achieve those
goals all day long
you will become more focused channeled
and directed you'll be more purposeful
and determined and you will achieve your
goals much faster than if they were
merely wishes floating around in the
back of your mind
writing and rewriting your goals each
day can give you your one thousand
percent increase in income over ten
years
step three
plan every day in advance
make a list and set priorities on your
work before you start off
your ability to set priorities and to
choose the most important thing that you
could be doing at every moment is the
key to organizing your life and doubling
your productivity
we'll talk in detail about time
management techniques in chapter 12.
working on your top priorities can
increase your income by one thousand
percent over ten years and it is
probably impossible to achieve without
it
step four
discipline yourself to concentrate
single-mindedly on one thing
choose the most important thing that you
can do each day
then start on it first thing and work on
it until it's 100 complete
your ability to focus and concentrate
when you develop and hone it into a
habit all by itself will enable you to
double your productivity performance and
output in the next month
and it will give you your one thousand
percent increase over ten years
step five
listen to educational audio programs in
your car
the average business person who drives
spends 500 to 1 000 hours per year
behind the wheel of their car
when you turn your car into a university
on wheels a mobile classroom
you get the educational equivalent of
one to two full-time university
semesters as you drive around
many people have gone from rags to
riches by simply listening to
educational audio programs in their cars
as they drive from place to place
you could do the same
this alone could give you your one
thousand percent increase
step number six ask two magic questions
after every call or event first ask
yourself what did i do right
then ask yourself
what would i do differently
the first question what did i do right
forces you to think through and recall
all the correct things that you did in
that last meeting presentation or event
even if it was not successful
write them down
the second question what would i do
differently forces you to think through
all the different ways you could improve
your performance in a similar situation
write these ideas down as well
in both cases by reviewing your
performance by thinking about what you
did right and what you would do
differently you program yourself to
perform even better the next time
this is one of the fastest and most
powerful exercises in personal growth
and development i have ever discovered
this process dramatically speeds up the
rate at which you move into the top
twenty percent
step seven treat every person you meet
like a million dollar customer
treat each person you meet and work with
both at home and in the office as though
he or she is the most important person
in the world
when you treat people as if they are
valuable and important they will return
the favor by treating you as if you are
valuable and important as well
they will want to be associated with you
work for you buy from you and introduce
you to their friends
you begin treating people like million
dollar customers by starting at home
with the members of your family
remember they are the most important
people in your life
so when you start your day well first
thing in the morning by making the
members of your family feel important
and telling them that you love them
you'll be more positive relaxed and
happier for the rest of the day
fully eighty-five percent of your
success will be determined by how much
people like and respect you especially
in business and sales
never miss an opportunity to treat
people well
when you practice these seven steps each
day for a month you will see changes and
improvements in your life work and
income that will astonish you
after a month of regular practice you'll
have formed a new habit of continuous
personal improvement that can carry you
onward and upward for the rest of your
life
be the best
lifelong personal development and the
commitment to personal excellence
requires tremendous dedication
discipline and willpower
the greatest payoff is that every time
you learn and apply something new your
brain releases endorphins which make you
feel happier and more excited about your
future
every time you learn and apply something
new you'll have a greater sense of
personal power your self-esteem
self-respect and personal pride will
increase you'll feel very much in
control of your earning ability which is
one of the most important parts of your
life
in the next chapter we'll talk about the
importance of courage of overcoming the
fears and doubts that hold most people
back
it is often the case that we know what
we need to do but we lack the courage to
take the risks that accompany trying
anything new
instead we make excuses for inaction
now here are some action exercises that
you can do
number one
make a decision today to invest in
yourself and getting better as if your
future depends on it because it does
two identify the most important skills
you have that determine the quality and
quantity of results you get at your work
and make a plan to get better in each
one
three
if you could wave a magic wand and
become absolutely excellent in any one
skill
which one skill would have the greatest
impact on your earning ability whatever
your answer set that skill as a goal
make a plan and work on it every day
four
set excellent performance in your work
as a goal
and then determine exactly what you will
need to do every day to join the top
twenty percent or better in your field
five
look ahead three to five years and
determine the new knowledge and skills
you will need in order to lead your
field in the future then start acquiring
them today
six
select the top person in your field the
one you admire most and use him or her
as a role model for your own development
and seven
commit yourself today to lifelong
learning and never let a day go by
without getting better in some area
chapter 6
self-discipline and courage
mark twain said courage is not absence
of fear it is control of fear mastery of
fear
you need large amounts of
self-discipline to deal courageously
with all the fear-inducing events of
your life
this is probably why churchill said
courage is rightly considered the
foremost of the virtues for upon it all
others depend
the fact is that everyone is afraid and
usually of many things
this is normal and natural
often fear is necessary to preserve life
prevent injury and guard against
financial mistakes
so if everyone is afraid what is the
difference between the brave person and
the coward
the only difference is that the brave
person disciplines himself to confront
deal with an act in spite of the fear
in contrast the coward allows himself to
be dominated and controlled by the fear
someone once said that with regard to
warfare although it applies to any
situation
the difference between the hero and the
coward is that the hero sticks in there
five minutes longer
fortunately all fears are learned no one
is born with fears fears can therefore
be unlearned by practicing
self-discipline repeatedly with regard
to fear until it goes away
the most common fears that we experience
which often sabotage all hopes for
success are the fears of failure poverty
and loss of money
these fears cause people to avoid risk
of any kind and to reject opportunity
when it's presented to them they're so
afraid of failure that they're almost
paralyzed when it comes to taking any
chances at all
there are many other fears that
interfere with our happiness
people fear the loss of love or the loss
of their jobs and their financial
security
people fear embarrassment or ridicule
people fear rejection criticism of any
kind
people fear the loss of respect or
esteem of others
these and many other fears hold us back
throughout life
fear paralyzes action
the most common reaction in a fear
situation is the attitude of i can't
this is the fear of failure and loss
that stops us from taking action
it is experienced physically starting in
the solar plexus
when a person is really afraid their
mouth and throat goes dry their heart
starts pounding sometimes they breathe
shallowly and their stomach turns often
they feel like getting up and running to
the bathroom
these are all physical manifestations of
the inhibitive negative habit pattern
which we all experience from time to
time
whenever a person is in the grip of fear
he feels like a deer caught in the
headlights of a car this fear paralyzes
action it often shuts down the brain and
causes the individual to revert to the
fight-or-flight reaction
fear is a terrible emotion that
undermines our happiness and can hold us
back throughout our lives
do the opposite
aristotle described courage as the
golden mean between the extremes of
cowardice and impetuousness
he taught that to develop a quality that
you lack act as if you already had that
quality in every situation where it is
called for
in modern terms however we say
fake it until you make it
you can actually change your behavior by
affirming visualizing and acting as if
you already have the quality you desire
by affirming by repeating the words i
can do it emphatically whenever you feel
afraid for any reason
you can cancel the feeling of i can't
every time you repeat the words i can do
it with conviction you override your
fear and increase your confidence
by repeating this affirmation over and
over again
you can eventually build your courage
and confidence to the point where you
are unafraid
visualize yourself as unafraid
by visualizing yourself performing with
confidence and confidence in an area
where you are fearful your visual image
will eventually be accepted by your
subconscious mind as instructions for
your performance
your self-image the way you see yourself
and think about yourself is eventually
altered by feeding your mind these
positive mental pictures of yourself
performing at your best
by using the act as if method you walk
talk and carry yourself exactly as you
would if you were completely unafraid in
a particular situation
you stand up straight smile move quickly
and confidently and in every respect act
as if you already had the courage that
you desire
the law of reversibility says that if
you feel a certain way you will act in a
manner consistent with that feeling
but if you act in a manner consistent
with that feeling even if you don't feel
it the law of reversibility will create
the feeling that is consistent with your
actions
this is one of the greatest
breakthroughs in success psychology
you develop the courage you desire by
disciplining yourself repeatedly to do
the thing you fear
until that fear eventually disappears
and it will
blow away the fear
when i work with sales organizations
they often ask me how to help a
salesperson break out of a sales slump
especially in a tough economy i give
them a simple formula that is guaranteed
to work every single time
it is called the 100 call method
in practicing this method i instruct the
salesperson to go out and call on 100
prospects as fast as he can without
caring at all whether or not he makes a
sale
when the salesperson doesn't care if he
makes a sale his fear of rejection
largely disappears
he stops caring if the prospect he is
speaking to is interested or not
interested he has a single focus it is
to make a hundred calls as fast as he
possibly can
one sales organization i work with has a
daily prize for the first salesperson
who gets rejected 10 times each morning
at 8 30 a.m all the salespeople sit down
at their desk and start making calls to
try to win the prize
by the time the contest is over usually
by 10 am
everyone's fears of rejection have been
blown out of their systems they're ready
to call on prospects all day long
not caring at all about the reactions
they get
learn to speak on your feet
in 1923 toastmasters international was
formed its express purpose was to take
people who were terrified of public
speaking and help them to become
confident and competent when speaking on
their feet in front of an audience
according to the book of lists 54 of
adults rate the fear of public speaking
ahead of the fear of death
but toastmasters international had a
solution
they created a system based on what
psychologists call systematic
desensitization
once a week at a luncheon or dinner
meeting small groups of toastmasters
come together each person is required to
stand up and give a short talk on a
specific subject in front of a group of
their peers
at the end of each talk the speaker
receives applause positive input and
comments from the other members
at the end of the evening each person is
given a grade on their talk even if it
was only for 30 or 60 seconds
after six months of attending
toastmasters meetings the individual
will have stood on his feet and spoken
26 times
receiving positive applause and feedback
each time
because of this continuous positive
reinforcement his confidence increases
dramatically
as a result of this process countless
toastmasters have gone on to become
excellent public speakers and prominent
people in their businesses
organizations and communities their
fears of public speaking are gone
forever
eliminate two fears at once
psychologists have found that certain
fears are bundled together in the
subconscious mind
like wires on the same circuit
if you can overcome your fears in one of
these areas you will also eliminate
other fears on the same circuit
the fear of rejection or call reluctance
seems to be bundled together with the
fear of public speaking
when you discipline yourself to join
toastmasters or to take a dale carnegie
course to learn to speak confidently on
your feet
your fears of rejection largely
disappear as well
your level of self-confidence in all
your interactions with others increases
dramatically your whole life changes in
a positive way
confront your fears
your ability to confront deal with and
act in spite of your fears is the key to
happiness and success one of the best
exercises you can practice is to
identify a person or situation in your
life of which you are afraid and resolve
to deal with that fear situation
immediately
do not allow it to make you unhappy for
another minute
resolve to confront the situation or
person and put the fear behind you
a woman in one of my seminars told me
that her boss was a very negative person
he was constantly criticizing and
berating her about her work even though
she was one of the highest rated
employees in the organization
he was making her life miserable
she didn't want to give up her job but
she was afraid of confronting him she
asked me what she should do
i gave her this advice which i've
subsequently given to many other people
the only reason that one person bullies
another is because they feel they can
get away with it
the only way to deal with a bully is to
confront him bullies are actually
cowards at heart and they will flee from
a confrontation
i told her to do this
the next time your boss criticizes you
for any reason
turn to him and say quite firmly i would
appreciate it if you not talk to me like
that ever again it hurts my feelings and
stops me from doing my job the way you
want
i told her to look him straight in the
eye after she had finished making this
statement
well she had tremendous courage rather
than putting up with this situation any
longer the next time her boss began to
berate her she squared off with him and
said those words
she wrote to me and told me what had
happened
just as i had predicted he stopped dead
in his tracks he immediately apologized
and mumbled and then quickly went back
to his office he never criticized her
again
she told me that she could have ended
his bad treatment of her many months
before if she had only had the courage
to confront him directly the first time
it happened
as eleanor roosevelt said
no one can make you feel inferior
without your consent
move toward the fear
when you identify a fear and discipline
yourself to move toward it it grows
smaller and more manageable
what's more as your fears grow smaller
your confidence grows larger
soon your fears lose their control over
you
in contrast when you back away from a
fear-inducing situation or person
your fear grows larger and larger
soon it dominates your thinking and
feeling preoccupies you during the day
and often keeps you awake at night
leaders have two types of courage
in leadership the most common quality is
that of vision
leaders have a clear vision of where
they want to take their organizations
leaders also have a clear vision of
where they want to be sometime in the
future in their personal lives
the second most common quality of
leaders is that of courage
leaders have the courage to do whatever
is necessary to fulfill their vision
they lead from the front and dare to go
forward
there are two types of courage that you
need
first you need the courage to launch to
take action to take a leap of faith
you need the courage to go all in
without any guarantee of success and
with a high possibility of failure at
least in the short term
the major feeling that holds most people
back is that in spite of all their best
intentions they don't have the courage
to take the first step
the second type of courage that you need
is called courageous patience
this is the ability to hang in there and
continue working and fighting after
you've gone all in and before you have
yet seen any results or rewards
many people can muster up the courage to
take action toward a new goal but when
they see no immediate result they
immediately lose heart and pull back to
safety and security they don't have
stain power
deal with the fear directly
the only way to deal with a fear is to
address it head on
remind yourself that denial is not a
river in egypt
the natural tendency of many people is
to deny that they have a problem caused
by a fear of some kind
they're afraid of confronting it in turn
it becomes a major source of stress
unhappiness and psychosomatic illness
be willing to deal with the situation or
person directly
as shakespeare said take arms against
the sea of troubles and in so doing end
them
the companion of fear is worry
like twin sisters fear and worry go
around together
mark twain once wrote
i have worried about a lot of things in
life and most of them never happened
it's been estimated that 99 of the
things that you worry about never happen
and most of the things that do happen
happen so quickly that you didn't have
time to worry about them in the first
place
the disaster report
whenever you're worried about something
fill out a disaster report on the
situation
this will destroy your fear and worry
almost instantly this is often called
the worry buster
the disaster report has four parts
first define the worry situation clearly
what exactly are you worried about
very often when you take the time to be
completely clear about the worry
situation
a way to resolve that situation becomes
immediately evident
second
identify the worst possible thing that
could happen if this worry situation
were to take place
would you lose your job would you lose
your relationship would you lose your
money what's the worst thing that could
possibly happen be clear about this
in many cases you will see that should
the worst occur it would not ruin you it
might be inconvenient or uncomfortable
but you would eventually recover
you will find that it's probably not
worth all the worry that you are
devoting to it
the third step in the disaster report is
to resolve to accept the worst possible
outcome should it occur
say to yourself well if that happens it
won't kill me i'll find a way to get
along
most of the stress of worry comes from
denial from not being willing to face
the worst possible thing that could
happen
but once you resolve to accept the worst
should it occur
all the worry and stress seems to
disappear
fourth begin immediately to improve on
the worst
take every step that you possibly can to
make sure that the worst possible
outcome does not occur
take action immediately do something get
on with it act quickly get so busy
making sure that the worst thing does
not happen that you have no time to
worry
the real antidote
in the final analysis the only real cure
for fear or worry is disciplined
purposeful action in the direction of
your goals get so busy working on your
goals or the solutions to your problems
that you have no time to be afraid or to
worry about anything
when you practice the self-discipline of
courage and force yourself to face any
fear-inducing situation in your life
your self-esteem goes up your
self-respect increases and your sense of
personal power grows
you eventually reach the point in life
where you're not afraid of anything
once you've developed the courage to
step out in faith you must then develop
the self-discipline of persistence which
we'll talk about in the next chapter
now here are seven action exercises for
you
one
identify your three biggest fears in
life right now
what are they
two
determine what you would do in each of
these situations if you are guaranteed
of complete success what actions would
you take
three what have you always wanted to do
but been afraid to attempt
what would you do differently if you
were guaranteed a success
four
in what three areas of life and work do
you most experience the fears of failure
and loss
what steps could you take immediately to
confront and eliminate those fears
five in what three areas of life do you
most experience the fears of criticism
rejection or embarrassment
how could you confront these fears and
overcome them
six
what one great goal would you set for
yourself if you knew you could not fail
and seven what would you do differently
in life if you had 20 million dollars in
the bank
but only 10 years left to live
chapter 7
self-discipline and persistence
benjamin disraeli wrote
beware of endeavoring to become a great
man in a hurry
one such attempt in ten thousand may
succeed these are fearful odds
persistence is self-discipline in action
your ability to persist in the face of
all setbacks and temporary failures is
essential to success in life
napoleon hill said persistence is to the
character of man as carbon is to steal
the primary reason for success is
persistence and likewise the primary
reason for failure is lack of
persistence or quitting too soon there's
a direct link between self-discipline
and self-esteem
each time you discipline yourself to do
what you should do when you should do it
whether you feel like it or not your
self-esteem increases
this is why there is a direct
relationship between self-esteem and
persistence
each time you persist and force yourself
to continue on even when you feel like
quitting your self-esteem goes up
each act of self-discipline strengthens
every other act of self-discipline
every act of persistence strengthens
every other act of persistence
when you discipline yourself to persist
over and over you like and respect
yourself more and more
you become stronger and more confident
eventually you become unstoppable
the reward of persistence
persistence is its own reward
every time you force yourself to persist
on a task whether it is large or small
you feel happier and better about
yourself
when you go the extra mile and do more
than you are paid for or more than is
expected your self-esteem goes up
you feel more powerful and in greater
control of your life
in your career when you go the extra
mile you put yourself on the side of the
angels
the primary difference between winners
and losers in life is simple winners
never quit and quitters never win
you can increase your ability to persist
by talking to yourself positively
say these words i am unstoppable before
you begin any major undertaking
pre-program yourself by telling yourself
i never give up
before you can achieve anything
worthwhile in life you have to pass the
persistence test
this is usually a snap quiz sprung on
you unexpectedly with no warning
you suddenly face a major setback
problem temporary failure or even a
complete disaster
when this happens remind yourself that
this is the testing time
this is when you demonstrate what you
are really made of this is when you show
yourself and others the strength of your
character and your true determination to
succeed
your ability to respond
your ability to respond effectively to
setbacks your level of response ability
is the measure of your readiness to
succeed
when you experience a major setback or
problem you will feel temporarily
stunned this feeling is very much like a
punch in the emotional solar plexus
you'll be stopped for a few seconds or a
few minutes
during this period you'll often feel
discouraged or experienced self-pity
you will say why me
however it is not how far you fall that
counts but rather how high you bounce
your aim is to bounce back as quickly as
possible
resilience in the face of unexpected
reversals is vital to long-term success
remember the warriors creed
i will lay me down to bleed a while and
then rise and fight again
don't be surprised shocked or set back
when things go wrong
your best laid plans will often fall
apart
instead expect disappointments and
setbacks as a part of life take a deep
breath pick up the pieces and continue
onward
optimism gives you resilience
the most important quality you need for
success and persistence is optimism
this is a boundless confidence in
yourself and your ability to ultimately
succeed
to remain optimistic you must control
and discipline your thinking when things
go wrong
refuse to feel sorry for yourself
remember you are not a victim you are an
adult and you are in charge of your own
life you are doing what you have freely
chosen to do
setbacks come with the territory they
are merely speed bumps on the road to
success
refuse to blame others or make excuses
when you complain or blame other people
it just makes you feel and sound petty
and small and what's worse it takes away
your personal power
whenever you criticize or complain it
makes you feel weaker and reduces your
ability to deal effectively with the
situation
instead greet every setback by repeating
i am responsible
look for the reasons why you are
responsible for what happened rather
than trying to pass on the blame to
other people
no excuses
be proactive versus reactive
resolve to focus on the solution and
what can be done now rather than on what
happened and who's to blame
think in terms of the actions you can
take to resolve the situation rather
than what went wrong and who is to blame
to remain optimistic look for the good
in every situation
when you look for something good you
will always find something good
furthermore while you're looking for
something good because your conscious
mind can only hold one thought at a time
you'll automatically become positive
optimistic and back in full control
seek the valuable lesson in every
problem or difficulty
every setback you face contains one or
more lessons that have been sent to you
to help you to be more successful in the
future
the difference between success and
failures is simple
failures feel sorry for themselves when
things go wrong
whereas successful people look for the
valuable lesson they can learn that will
help them in the future
look for the gift
norman vincent peel used to say when god
wants to send you a gift he wraps it up
in a problem
the bigger the gift that god wants to
send you the bigger the problem he wraps
it up in
instead of concentrating on the problem
look for the gift
wonderfully enough you will always find
it what's more sometimes the gift or
valuable lesson can be a far greater
value than the cost of the problem
itself
sometimes one lesson that you learn in
dealing with a problem can be the key to
your long-term success
as napoleon hill wrote within every
problem or obstacle lies the seed of an
equal or greater opportunity or benefit
your job is to find it
continually think of yourself as a
strong powerful resolute person in the
face of adversity
in world war one a british general was
described by his superiors
there he stands like an iron peg
driven into the frozen ground immovable
let this be an accurate description of
you whenever you face difficulties or
problems of any kind
resolve to stand like an iron peg
driven into the frozen ground
resolve in advance
when you resolve in advance that you
will never give up your success is
virtually guaranteed
in the final analysis nothing can really
stop you
but yourself
in life it doesn't matter how many times
you get knocked down all that matters is
how many times you get back up
if you continue to get back up and press
onward you must eventually reach your
goal
each time you exert your self-discipline
to persist in the face of adversity you
also increase your self-esteem and
self-confidence
then as your self-esteem increases you
feel stronger more powerful and more
unstoppable
when you feel better and stronger you
become more capable of persisting the
next time and then the time after that
by disciplining yourself to persist in
the face of all adversity you put your
life onto an upward spiral of
self-esteem self-discipline and
persistence until you eventually become
like a force of nature
persistence is self-discipline in action
in part two you will learn the specific
things you can do to apply these
principles to the practical areas of
life to achieve greater success in your
work and career and to fulfill your
potential in the months and years ahead
now here are some action exercises for
you
number one identify one area in your
life where you need to persist even
harder to achieve your goal
and then take action in that area
two
identify a goal in your life that you
did not accomplish because you failed to
persist through to completion
what steps could you take today to
succeed in that area
three
identify one big goal that you achieved
because you persisted and refused to
give up no matter how difficult it
became
four
decide on your major definite purpose in
life that one goal that if you achieved
it would have the greatest positive
impact on your life
five
write down your goal clearly make a
detailed plan of action to accomplish it
and then tell yourself that failure is
not an option
six
make a decision today that you will
persist until you succeed no matter what
happens because
i am
unstoppable seven
resolve to set and achieve one important
goal overcoming the inevitable
difficulties problems and setbacks you
will experience and work on it until you
succeed
repeat this process over and over until
persistence becomes a habit
part two
self-discipline in business sales and
finances
in this part you will learn how to
develop the discipline necessary to join
the top ten percent of people in your
field
you'll learn how to increase your
productivity performance output and
results
you'll learn how to become one of the
most respected and esteemed people in
your organization and your industry
chapter 8
self-discipline and work
vince lombardi said leaders aren't born
they are made and they're made just like
anything else through hard work and
that's the price we'll have to pay to
achieve that goal or any goal
there is perhaps no area of your life
where self-discipline has a greater
impact on your future than in your work
yet if you're like most people from the
time you start in the morning and then
continuing throughout the day you're
surrounded by people and events that
draw you away from doing the things that
are most important however it is through
doing your most important tasks that you
move onward and upward quickly and
dependably in your career
a group of senior executives was asked
what are the most important qualities
that a person would need to be promoted
in your company
of these executives 85 percent agree
that the most important qualities are
one the ability to set priorities and
work on high value tasks and two the
discipline to get the job done quickly
and well
it seems that these two qualities are
more helpful for career success than
anything else a person could do
diligent disciplined focused work will
enable you to get consistently and
predictably more done get paid more and
get promoted faster throughout your
career than the average person
separate the relevant from the
irrelevant
i've mentioned the pareto principle the
80 20 rule several times in this book
and it applies again here
fully eighty percent of the value of
what you accomplish will come from
twenty percent of the things you do
your job then is to identify those top
twenty percent of your tasks and then
concentrate single-mindedly undoing them
quickly and well
chapter thirteen discusses time
management in detail but for now let's
take a look at the flip side of good
time management
poor time management according to robert
half international the average employee
wastes about 50 percent of his or her
time on non-work related activities
37 percent of work time is wasted on
idle conversation on personal subjects
with co-workers
conversations that have nothing whatever
to do with the job at hand
the other thirteen percent of wasted
time is consumed by coming in late or
leaving early by long lunches and coffee
breaks by surfing the internet reading
the newspaper or conducting personal
business during the day
even worse when people who waste a lot
of time actually settle down and get to
work
they spend too much time on low value
tasks and activities
as a result they get very little done
which then causes them to feel that they
are under continual pressure to get
caught up
unfortunately when you waste time at
work your work does not go away it
continually builds like an avalanche
overhang
deadlines come closer and closer
stress mounts up until you finally force
yourself to do the job usually at the
last minute and then you often make
expensive mistakes
develop an excellent reputation
there is nothing that will bring you to
the attention of people who can help you
faster than for you to develop a
reputation for hard disciplined work
every hour of every day
average employees increase their income
at only about three percent per year
which is just about the rate of
inflation or cost of living increases
in other words if you're an average
employee you're not really making any
more money from year to year
rather you're just keeping up with your
expenses
but the top twenty percent in most
fields increase their income anywhere
from ten to twenty five percent per year
which is also compounded year after year
the top twenty percent of people at work
earn eighty percent of the money
the bottom eighty percent of employees
have no choice but to share the twenty
percent of the money that is left over
they must scramble for the crumbs that
fall off the tables of the highly
productive people in their fields
you can double your income
when i say to people in my seminars that
you should set a goal to double your
income in the months and years ahead
people react in different ways often at
the break someone will come up to me and
say
you don't understand my company there's
no way that i could double my income at
my current company they simply would not
pay me that amount of money
having heard this before i then ask them
the critical question
is there anyone at your company who
earns twice as much as you do
the person that i'm talking to will
always agree that yes there are people
in my company or two or three times as
much as i do i then make the key point
so your company is quite willing to pay
some people twice as much as they pay
you
they're just not willing to pay you
twice as much why is that
then suddenly the light goes on
the individual realizes that it is not
the company that is not willing to pay
the money it is the individual who is
not contributing enough to be worth that
additional money
the responsibility is his not the
companies
the law of three helps you to prioritize
when we coach entrepreneurs executives
and business owners we take them through
an exercise that is designed to help
them double their productivity
performance and output within 12 months
sometimes even within 30 days
it's simple here's how it works
first make a list of all the things that
you do in a week or a month from the
time you start work on monday morning
through to the end of the week
write down everything both small and
large including checking your email and
returning phone calls
then review this list and ask this key
question
if i could only do one thing on this
list
all day long which one task or activity
contributes the most value to my company
as you go over your list the correct
answer will probably jump out at you
whatever it is put a circle around it
then
ask the second question
if i could only do two things on this
list all day long
which would be the second task or
activity
review your list again and identify your
second most important task in terms of
contribution to your company
finally ask the question once more
if i could only do three things on this
list all day long what would be the
third item
we call this the law of three
the law of three says that there are
three primary things that you do that
contribute 90 or more of your value to
your company or organization
your job is to identify those three
critical tasks
and then discipline yourself to do them
all day long
all of your other minor tasks will be
support tasks complementary tasks
enjoyable tasks or useless tasks
they will be little things that you've
gotten into the habit of doing as a way
of unconsciously avoiding the big
difficult important tasks that can make
a tremendous difference in your work and
career
calculate your hourly rate
another way for you to double your
income is for you to use the hourly rate
method of calculating your personal
value and your time allocation
first determine the amount that you earn
each hour
you do this by dividing your annual
income by the number 2000
which is roughly the number of hours
that an entrepreneur or executive works
each year in our society
40 hours a week times fifty weeks a year
for example if you earn fifty thousand
dollars a year divided by two thousand
your hourly rate would be twenty five
dollars
if you earn one hundred thousand dollars
per year divided by two thousand your
hourly rate would be fifty dollars
whatever it is from that moment onward
resolve to do only those things that pay
you your hourly rate or better
refuse to do those things that someone
else can do at a lower hourly rate than
you
do not waste your time doing things so
low value or no value while your other
important tasks are building up
get on the same page about what work is
most important
once you have made a list of all the
results you feel you have been hired to
accomplish and you have determined your
three most important things that you do
to justify your hourly rate
take your list of key activities to your
boss
and have your boss organize your job
based on his or her priorities
you need to do this because you must be
sure
benjamin trigo co-founder of the kaepner
trego consulting firm and author of the
rational manager
once said the very worst use of time is
to do very well what need not be done at
all
yet it is amazing how many people are
working hard on tasks that are little or
no value to their bosses
no matter how well you do an unimportant
task it doesn't help you even worse
working on low value tasks keep you from
working on the most important things you
could be doing
hard work on the wrong job can actually
sabotage your career
the happiest days you will have at work
will be when you are working on those
tasks that your boss considers to be the
most important the unhappiest days at
work will be when you and your boss are
at cross purposes and not getting along
primarily because you are not completing
the jobs that are most important to him
and to his career
your goal is to be paid more and
promoted faster
your goal is to become one of the most
valuable and highest paid people in your
field
your job is first to make yourself
valuable and then to make yourself
indispensable to your company
this requires first and foremost that
you are always working on those tasks
your boss considers most important
work all the time you work
the key to doubling your productivity
and output and eventually your income is
to really work all the time you're at
work
simply put when you work a work don't
waste time don't delay
don't chat with co-workers or sit around
drinking coffee don't read the newspaper
or surf the internet when you come into
work in the morning put your head down
and then work all day long
the biggest time wasters in the world of
work are other people who want to talk
with you distract you delay you and take
up the time that you should be spending
on high value tasks
when a time waster approaches you and
says do you have a minute to talk you
reply by saying yes but not now why
don't we talk at lunch time or after
work in the meantime i have to get this
job finished i have to get back to work
when you tell people that you're under
the gun that you have to get a task
finished for your boss they will usually
leave you alone if you do this often
enough they will develop the habit of
leaving you alone and instead find
someone else with whom to waste time
keep yourself motivated and focused by
talking to yourself in a positive way
your mantra from now on should be
back to work back to work back to work
whenever you find yourself slowing down
on a major task begin repeating to
yourself those magic words
back to work
who works hardest
the secret survey
imagine that an outside company is going
to do a study of all the people who work
in your organization
they're going to give each person a list
of all the employees and ask them to
rate their fellow employees
in terms of who works the hardest the
second hardest and so on
they're then going to give this list of
people organized from the hardest worker
down to the laziest to your superiors
this list is going to be used to
determine who gets paid more and
promoted faster than others
now
imagine that this survey is already
being taken but in secret
the fact is in any organization everyone
knows who works harder than anyone else
everyone knows who works less and who
does not pull their weight
everyone knows it's not a secret at all
resolve today that if a survey like this
were to be taken one year from today you
would win the contest
resolve today that you are going to
develop the reputation for being the
hardest working person in your business
this will do more to help you than
almost anything else
when you are surrounded by time wasting
people in situations it takes tremendous
self-discipline to work all the time
you're at work
you must constantly fight against
distractions and interruptions so that
you can get back to work
the success formula
when i began my career working for a
large company i was the low man on the
totem pole
everyone had been there longer than me
and was ahead of me in the company
pecking order
even though i was in my early thirties i
still had no idea how to play the game
or what to do to get ahead in the
cutthroat corporate competition that
existed
somewhat by accident i stumbled onto the
formula that made me successful it was
very simple
whenever my boss gave me something to do
i did it immediately
like a dog chasing after a throwing
stick i would immediately throw myself
at the task completed and hurry back to
my boss with a finished jaw
initially he would smile and say
something like i didn't really need it
done that quickly but thank you for
getting it done
i was caught up with my work instead of
relaxing i would go to my boss and say
i'm all caught up i want more work to do
i want more responsibility
these words became my mantra i want more
responsibility
again my boss who was preoccupied with
an enormous number of projects would say
something like okay leave it with me
i'll think about what else i can give
you to do
every day like a broken record i would
go to my boss at the end of the day and
say
i'm all caught up i would like more
responsibility
bit by bit he began to toss me sticks
he would give me a little task to do to
keep me busy
whatever it was i would go out
immediately complete the task and bring
in the results i would then say i'm all
caught up i want more responsibility
within six months he began to see me as
the go-to guy
whenever he had something he needed done
quickly he passed by everyone else and
gave it to me
he knew that whatever he asked me to do
i would do it quickly
once my boss asked me to fly to reno to
begin development work on a property
that the company was purchasing
he told me i could go sometime in the
next couple of weeks
instead i left the next morning
i went straight to the lawyer who was
handling the transaction and then to the
engineer who was in charge of the
development work
i immediately sensed that something was
seriously wrong with this land purchase
i didn't know what it was but as i went
from person to person asking questions
and gathering information
by the end of the day just a few hours
before this two million dollar
transaction was set to close
and the money would change hands forever
i found that we were about to be sold a
piece of land that had no water and was
therefore undevelopable
because of complex laws and limited
riparian rights water rights the
property was a worthless piece of ground
that could not be developed within the
next hundred years
if we had proceeded with the purchase we
would have lost two million dollars
i immediately stopped the transaction
demanded that the lawyer cut me a
certified check for the 250 000 deposit
that was in his trust account and flew
home to my boss to tell him the story
as you can imagine my boss was very
happy with what i had done
from that day forward i received more
and more responsibilities
within another year i was running three
divisions of the company and had a staff
of 42 people in three cities
i later learned that my boss paid me
more money than anyone else who ever
worked for him
and he did so all on the basis of
results and profitability
this is why whenever people ask me how
to succeed in business by really trying
i give them the same advice
whatever your boss gives you to do do it
quickly and well
then go and ask for more responsibility
and when you get it do the job quickly
and well until you get a reputation for
being the person who does things fast
this will help you advance in your
career more than any other reputation
you could develop
pay the price
here is a simple three-part formula for
success at work
come in a little earlier work a little
harder and stay a little later
this will move you so far ahead of your
competitors that they will never catch
up
come into work one hour earlier before
anyone else arrives
use that time to plan and organize your
day and get started on your most
important tasks
make sure that whatever time your boss
comes to work you are always there
working before he arrives
second work a little harder don't waste
time don't chat with co-workers work
through lunch time so that you can get
on top and stay on top of your main
tasks and responsibilities
third
work one hour later than your co-workers
if they leave at five o'clock you leave
at six
use that extra time to complete your
important tasks and get yourself
organized for the following day
when you come in one hour earlier work
through lunch and work one hour later
you add three full productive hours to
your day
because there are no interruptions when
you work during these time periods
you'll actually accomplish two or three
times as much as you would during your
other work hours when you're constantly
interrupted by other people in telephone
calls
in fact you can double or even triple
your productivity performance and output
by simply adding these three hours to
your workday
the good news is that by coming in
earlier and leaving later you don't lose
anything you merely avoid the traffic
tie-ups and slow downs and most people
suffer through on their ways to and from
work
the 40 plus formula to succeed faster at
work use the 40 plus formula
this formula says that you can tell
where you're going to be five years from
now by looking at the number of hours
that you put in today in excess of 40
hours per week
if all you do is put in the regular 40
hours that everyone else puts in all you
will do is survive
your annual increases will be three or
four percent
you will have a job but your income
increases will go up at the same rate as
everyone else
it is when you begin to put in more than
40 hours that you give yourself an
advantage over most of the other people
in your company and your business
make it a habit to do more than what you
are paid for discipline yourself to put
in more than you take out
every hour that you work over 40 hours a
week is an investment in your future
success
the highest paid people in america in
every field work 50 to 60 hours per week
the average self-made millionaire works
59 hours per week this is equal to five
12-hour days or six 10-hour days
most successful people at the beginning
of their careers work six days a week
sometimes seven moreover they worked all
the time they were at work
they didn't waste time they realized
that in order to reap a great harvest
later in their career they had to sow a
lot of seeds in the springtime of their
career
look the part dress for success
finally to succeed at work you need to
discipline yourself to look the part
remember birds of a feather flock
together
when it comes to presentation this means
that people like to promote others who
look like them
your bosses are very sensitive to the
appearance of their staff they like to
promote people who they are proud to
introduce to their friends and
colleagues
be sure that you dress and groom in such
a way that your boss would be proud to
take you out for lunch and introduce you
to others as a representative of his or
her company
each morning before you go to work look
in the mirror and ask yourself do i look
like one of the top people in my field
if you don't go back and change and keep
changing until you look like one of the
top people in your business
learn how to dress for success
read books and articles or ask others
for advice
look at the most successful people in
your business and dress the way they do
dress for the job two levels above your
current job remember that fully
ninety-five percent of the first
impression you make on other people will
be determined by your dress and grooming
make sure that that first impression and
then the second and third impressions
are consistent with the message you want
to send
many people work their entire lives
without realizing that by putting
forward a little extra effort working a
little harder and focusing on higher
value tasks they could become one of the
most valuable people in their
organizations
when you discipline yourself to
continually increase the value of your
contribution to your company
you'll put your career on the fast track
and virtually guarantee yourself a
wonderful future
in the next chapter
you will learn that your work behaviors
naturally determine your ascension to
leadership and you will see how
self-discipline is essential to
fulfilling your potential as a leader
now here are some action exercises for
you
number one
make a decision today that you're going
to become one of the top 20 of people in
your company and your industry
what should you or could you do
differently to achieve that goal
two
make a list of everything you do in your
job and then identify the three things
that contribute the greatest value to
your work and your company
three
set a new work schedule for yourself and
begin to start earlier work harder and
stay later until it becomes a habit
four
identify the most important results you
are expected to achieve in your job and
then work on those results all day long
five
determine the person who is the best
dressed and groomed in your company and
then resolve to use him or her as a role
model for your own appearance
six
decide today that from now on you're
going to actually work all the time
you're at work and that you are going to
develop the reputation for being the
hardest working person in your company
and seven
develop a sense of urgency
resolve to move fast when you're given a
job or opportunity
this can change your life
chapter 9
self-discipline and leadership
nothing is more harmful to the service
than the neglect of discipline
for it is disciplined more than numbers
that gives one army superiority over
another
george washington
leadership and self-discipline go hand
in hand it is not possible to imagine an
effective leader who lacks
self-discipline willpower self-control
and self-mastery
the overarching characteristic of a
leader is that he is in complete control
of himself and every situation
there seldom been a time in history when
leaders were so needed and so much in
demand as today
we need leaders at every level of
society both in the profit and
non-profit sectors
we need leaders in our families
businesses places of worship community
organizations and especially politics
we need men and women who take their
responsibilities seriously and are
willing to step forward to take command
of the situation
fortunately leadership is learnable
leaders are developed usually
self-developed over time through hard
work experience and training
as peter drucker once said there may be
natural-born leaders but there are so
few of them that they make no difference
in the great scheme of things
four stages of development
in your career in business you progress
through four levels of activity and
attainment
first you start off as an employee with
limited knowledge and experience
then as you grow learn and develop the
ability to get results you evolve upward
and become a supervisor with
responsibility for the performance and
results of other people
as you continue to move up the scale of
supervision improving your ability to
get things done through others from
directly overseeing the work of
employees you become a manager someone
who assigns work to people with
demonstrated competence in certain areas
managers have a larger view
and this comes with greater
responsibilities
as you move up the scale of management
becoming more knowledgeable and
effective in getting more and better
results from more and different people
you reach the highest level that of a
leader at this stage you are responsible
for determining what is to be done
rather than how it is to be done
it is said that some leaders are made
some are born and some people have
leadership thrust upon them
leaders emerge or are promoted to deal
with a situation requiring leadership
ability
in its simplest terms the role of the
leader is to take responsibility for
results
the primary reason that people are
promoted into increasingly higher levels
of leadership is because they
demonstrate the ability to get the
required results at each level
the ongoing question of the leader is
always what results are expected of me
clarity is essential the main reason
that some people are not promoted into
greater leadership positions or perhaps
they are even fired is because of
failure to execute
they do not do the most important jobs
expected of them nor do they get the
results demanded of them
leaders have vision
the first quality of leadership based on
3 300 studies of leaders reviewed by
james mcpherson is the quality of vision
leaders have vision they have the
ability to project forward into the
future and develop a clear picture of
where they want their organizations to
go
they then have the ability to share this
vision with others and gain others
commitment to make this vision a reality
you become a leader when you accept
responsibility for results
you become a leader when you begin to
think act and talk like a leader
you become a leader when you develop a
vision for yourself and for your company
your life or your area of responsibility
there are hundreds of books written
about leadership and the importance of
vision
yet they can be boiled down to a single
principle
a military leader has a vision of
victory from which he never deviates
a business leader has a vision of
success for the business based on
excellent performance to which he or she
is completely committed
a leader is a standard bearer
the leader sets the standard for the
organization or the department
it is not possible for anyone in the
organization to have a clear vision or
to aspire to a higher standard of
excellence than the leader
for this reason the leader is the role
model the one who sets the tone and the
morale for everyone in the organization
the personality and influence of the
leader affects everyone below him in the
company organization or department
you cannot raise morale in a business it
filters down from the top from the
leader
the behavior of the leader influences
and affects the behavior of everyone
else
if the leader is positive confident and
upbeat
everyone in the organization will be
influenced by his behavior and will be
more confident
positive and upbeat as well
walk the talk
when you become a leader you must
discipline yourself to be leader like
you must walk talk and act the part of a
leader
you become a different person with
different responsibilities than a
manager
when you are working your way up you are
a part of the staff or the sales team
when you become a manager you are part
of management this means that when you
are part of the staff your orientation
is upward and sideways
but when you become a leader your
orientation is downward toward all the
people for whom you are responsible
perhaps the most important behavior of a
leader is for you to discipline yourself
to be a role model
imagine that everyone is watching you
and patterning everything they do and
say based on your behavior
when you become a leader you no longer
have the luxury to let it all hang out
from the time you are promoted into
leadership you have a special
responsibility to discipline and control
your words and behaviors in such a way
so that you bring about the very best
possible results for your organization
and for other people
set the standards
the leader sets the standards for the
organization's behavior
quality of work
personal organization time management
and appearance
in excellent organizations the leader is
the person who everyone looks up to and
wants to emulate
in most cases the leader works harder
than others in the company
the leader appears to be more committed
more determined more courageous
more visionary and more persistent than
anyone else
the leader sets a tone that everyone
wants to emulate
the leader also sets the standard for
how people are treated in the
organization
when the leader treats people with
courtesy consideration and concern
it quickly becomes known that these are
the standards to which others must
adhere
set values and principles
in addition to a clear vision for the
organization the leader must have a set
of values and organizing principles that
guide behavior and decision making
everyone must know what the leader and
the company stands for and believes in
the job of the leader then is to
articulate this vision of excellent
performance within the constraints of
high ethical standards at all times
he or she must walk the talk and live
the values and behaviors he or she
teaches
the very best standard for a leader is
the golden rule
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you
for example when jack welch was the
president of general electric
he encouraged managers to treat each
employee as if that employee might be
promoted over his head sometime in the
future
and he might find himself working under
the person who is now working below him
this way of thinking assured that
managers treated their staff with a high
degree of respect and courtesy
seven principles of leadership
to be an effective leader there are
seven principles you must incorporate
into your leadership behavior and
activities
one clarity
this is perhaps your most important
responsibility you must be absolutely
clear about who you are and what you
stand for
you must be absolutely clear about your
vision and where you want to lead your
people
you must be absolutely clear about the
goals and objectives of the organization
and how they are to be achieved
especially you must be absolutely clear
about the values
mission and purpose of the organization
and what it stands for
everyone around you and below you must
know exactly why they are doing what
they do
and what their company has been formed
to accomplish
two
competence
as the leader you must set a standard of
excellent performance for the
organization as well as for every person
and function in the company
your goal must be for your company to be
as good or better than your very best
competitor
you must be continually seeking ways to
improve the quality of your product and
services to your customers
three commitment
the leader is absolutely committed to
the success of the organization and
believes completely that this
organization is the best in the business
or will be the best in the future
this passionate commitment to the
organization and to success and
achievement
motivates and inspires people to do
their best work
and put their whole hearts into their
jobs
four
constraints the job of the leader is to
identify the constraints or limiting
factors that set the speed at which the
company achieves its most important
goals of revenue and profitability
the leader then allocates people and
resources to alleviate those constraints
and remove the obstacles so it can
perform as one of the best in the
business
five creativity
the leader is open to new ideas of all
kinds and from all sources
the leader is continually encouraging
people to find faster better cheaper and
easier ways to produce excellent
products and services and to take better
care of customers
number five continuous learning the
leader is personally committed to
reading listening and upgrading his or
her personal knowledge and skills as an
executive
the leader should attend additional
seminars and courses to improve his or
her skills and abilities
at the same time the leader encourages
everyone in the organization to learn
and grow as a normal and natural part of
business life
the leader provides time and resources
for training and development
the leader knows that the best companies
have the best trained people the second
best companies have the second best
trained people
and the third best companies have the
least trained people and are on their
way out of business
number seven is consistency
the leader has the self-discipline to be
consistent dependable reliable calm and
predictable in all situations
one of the great comforts of business
life is for an employee to know that the
leader is completely consistent and
reliable
an effective leader does not change from
day to day the leader is not blown in
the wind by each new situation or
problem or emergency that arises instead
the leader is calm positive and
confident especially under pressure
the inevitable crisis
the only thing that is inevitable in the
life of the leader is the crisis
when you rise to a position of
leadership you will experience crises
repeatedly crises that are unpredictable
unbidden and often capable of seriously
damaging the organization
it is in the crisis that the leader
demonstrates his competence
in times of crisis the leader becomes
calm cool objective and completely in
control
the leader asks questions and gathers
information
the leader assesses the situation
accurately and makes whatever decisions
are necessary to minimize the damage or
cut the losses
great leaders discipline themselves to
keep their fears and misgivings private
they do not share their concerns with
their staffs knowing that this can cause
confusion and loss of morale
instead the leader asks a lot of
questions probes deeply into situations
so that he or she understands them
thoroughly and keeps his or her feelings
private
as far as the members of the
organization are concerned the leader is
always calm
positive relaxed and in complete control
no matter what is happening
self-control and leadership
there's a direct relationship between
your ability to discipline yourself and
your behaviors and your readiness to
lead
it is only when you prove to others that
you are in complete control of yourself
that they develop the confidence to put
you in a leadership position
and keep you there
the leader realizes that everything he
says to or about another person is
magnified
the leader therefore praises and
encourages people both in their presence
and when they are not around
he never says anything negative that
could be misinterpreted or that could
demotivate or offend another person
if he has problems with someone he
addresses them privately
out of sight and earshot of anyone else
leadership qualities
leaders discipline themselves to plan
prepare organize and check every detail
they take nothing for granted
they ask questions to ensure that they
have a complete understanding of a
situation problem or difficulty
great leaders act as if they own the
entire company they accept a high level
of personal responsibility
the leader never complains makes excuses
or blames others for problems
leaders are intensely action-oriented
they gather information carefully and
they make the decisions that are
necessary they set measures and
standards and hold others to them
they insist that the job be done
quickly and well
leaders rise to the top
leaders rise to the top of an
organization as cream rises in milk
when you accept complete responsibility
for getting results
concentrate single-mindedly on
completing your most important tasks
continually upgrade your knowledge and
skills as well as your ability to
contribute value to your company
and treat other people with kindness and
consideration you will emerge as a
natural leader
as you demonstrate your ability to make
an increasingly valuable contribution to
your organization people above below and
on both sides of you will want you to be
promoted into leadership and will
support you when you reach that position
one of your primary aims in life is to
walk talk act speak and treat others as
a leader would
eventually your position will be equal
to your performance
in the next chapter you will learn how
to develop and practice the disciplines
necessary to be more successful in your
business life and activities
now here are seven action exercises that
come from this chapter
one ask yourself what results are
expected of me
and then concentrate single-mindedly on
getting those results every day
two see yourself as the leader of your
organization and ask yourself
what kind of a company would this
company be
if everyone in it were just like me
number three
create a clear exciting vision for
yourself and your organization
based on success and excellent
performance
number four
identify the most important people in
your business world and determine how
you will have to behave toward them
to get them to perform at their best
number five resolve in advance that when
the inevitable crisis occurs you will
respond in a calm controlled and
intelligent manner
number six clarify the exact values and
principles you believe in and stand for
and then share them with the people
around you
and number seven
treat each person around you as if they
are competent valuable and important
this is the key to gaining the loyalty
and commitment
that you require as a leader
chapter 10
self-discipline and business
john viney wrote
the quality of self-denial in the
pursuit of a longer-term goal and indeed
the willpower to maintain that level of
self-denial is an excellent training for
the boardroom
most people will work in or for a
business or own a business in the course
of their lifetimes
the achievement of business success
demands high levels of discipline from
you in every area of business activity
both large or small
without self-discipline and self-control
in business no success is possible
there's no area of activity that demands
more self-discipline than starting and
operating a successful business in our
current economy
the first law of economics is scarcity
as a rule there is never enough of
anything for everyone who wants it
specifically there are never enough
customers for you to sell everything you
want to sell there are never enough
sales revenues to help you achieve all
your financial goals
there are never sufficient profits to
enable you to expand as much as you want
especially there are never enough good
people to work with and for you to help
you achieve your business goals
the law of competition
if the first law of economics is
scarcity then the first law of business
is competition
it requires tremendous focus and
discipline to do the things necessary
to attract the scarce money of customers
toward purchasing your product or
service
to not only survive but also thrive you
must compete continually against all
other uses of the same amount of money
that you want to charge for what you
sell
the first discipline of business success
is that you offer a product or service
that people want need and will pay for
at a price they will accept a price that
is competitive with every other business
that wants the same customer dollar
you must be completely honest with your
product service mix to ensure that it is
well suited to the current market
this is an area where false assumptions
or incorrect conclusions can lead to
business failure this answer is
continually changing as competition and
customer tastes also change
the customer is always right
every week i speak to business people
who are unhappy with their levels of
sales and profitability
they insist that their product or
service is excellent and that people
should be buying from them in a much
larger quantity
in each case i have to gently point out
to them that the only proof that their
product or service is truly attractive
or valuable is that people buy it
willingly and then buy it again and tell
their friends to buy it as well
according to the experts fully seventy
percent of your business decisions will
turn out to be wrong in the fullness of
time
this is the average
when you're a new business person or
starting a new business you'll be wrong
even more often than this
it's not unusual for an entrepreneur to
be wrong ninety percent of the time in
the beginning of his or her career
it requires tremendous self-discipline
and character to face the possibility
that you could be wrong in your most
cherished assumptions and beliefs
nonetheless this discipline is essential
if you're going to minimize your
mistakes cut your losses and redirect
your resources toward offering customers
more
of the things that they really want need
and are willing to pay for
all business investment and business
startups require a high level of
optimism
you must believe in the future
possibilities of your business
along with your new products and
services
you must have so much confidence in
their marketability that you're willing
to undertake financial risk and invest
many hours weeks and even years to
achieve your business goals and you must
do all of this with no real guarantee of
success
at the same time you need discipline to
curb your confidence to remain objective
and realistic
overconfidence in business can lead to
business mistakes financial losses and
even bankruptcy
you must be better
because of the aggressive and determined
nature of your competition in order to
simply survive you must discipline
yourself to be equal to or better than
your competitors
after all your competitors get out of
bed every morning thinking about how
they can put you out of business
they want to take away your customers
and your sales they want to get your
profits they want as much of your
business as they can possibly get
to increase your probabilities of
success against such competition you
must make every effort to out-think them
when you start a business or a new
venture within a business
you require the discipline to do your
homework thoroughly in advance
you create a complete business plan
before you start operations and you
continue to update it and revise it
every year thereafter
the discipline of advanced planning can
spell the difference between success and
failure
challenge your assumptions
most business ideas do not work at least
in their original form
as peter drucker said errant assumptions
lie at the root of every failure
a major reason for business failure is
that the business owner or executive
relies on assumptions that are not
tested
they assume that the product or service
is excellent in comparison with others
they assume they can sell a sufficient
number of those products or services and
do so at a profit
they further assume that those profits
will be substantial enough to make this
investment of time and money more
attractive than any other use of the
same amount of time or funds
all of these assumptions must be tested
carefully before any irrevocable
commitment is made
according to the kauffman foundation on
entrepreneurship 95 percent of
entrepreneurs and small business owners
in america
earn less than 50 dollars per year
why is this
it's not because they lack the energy
intelligence or ability to earn more
the very fact that a person has the
courage and resourcefulness to start a
new business
means that he or she has above average
levels of natural talent
the reason why so many entrepreneurs
underachieve and fail is because they
lack discipline
they lack the discipline to carefully
study every aspect of the business
before committing to it
they lack the discipline to test their
assumptions rather than jumping to
conclusions and hoping for the best
don't let this happen to you
identify your ideal customer
you need discipline to identify and
determine your ideal customer
the exact person who can and will buy
your product or service in sufficient
quantities and at the price you need to
charge in order to justify going into
this area of business in the first place
you need the discipline based on trial
error and persistence to develop a
marketing plan that generates a steady
and predictable stream of new leads for
your business
to market effectively you must be clear
about your competitive advantage and
your unique selling proposition
what is it about your product or service
that makes it superior and more valuable
for a customer than any other similar
product or service being offered today
you need the discipline to develop a
complete sales system from beginning to
end
that converts qualified leads into solid
customers
it's amazing how many businesses just
assume that the product or service will
sell itself
whether they have a superior sales
system or not
know your true costs
you need the discipline to determine
accurate costs and the proper pricing of
your products and services
walmart has become the biggest retailer
in history largely because of its
expertise in this area
it's amazing how many businesses are
selling products and services at a loss
because they've never accurately totaled
all the costs of bringing that product
or service to market in the first place
you've heard the old saying we lose
money on every item we sell but we try
to make it up on the volume
obviously that's not possible
you need a quality control system in
order to ensure that every product or
service that you sell is of such high
quality that your customers are so
satisfied that they happily buy from you
again and tell their friends
you need the discipline to develop a
customer service policy
one in which you treat your customers so
well that they become loyal to you and
choose you over any of your competitors
the purpose of a business is to please
your customers
what is the purpose of a business the
purpose of a business is to create and
keep a customer in a cost-effective
manner
profits are not the purpose of a
business profits are the result of
creating and keeping a sufficient number
of customers who yield a sufficient
number of profits after all costs
what is the key measure of business
success
the answer is customer satisfaction
every effort and activity of your
business must be aimed at satisfying
customers
in a manner that is better than any
other competitor
what is the measure of customer
satisfaction
the answer is repeat business
it is only when customers buy from you
again that you demonstrate that you have
fulfilled the promise you made to them
when you got them to purchase the first
time
a resale to a satisfied customer
requires one tenth of the time and
expense as a sale to a brand new
customer
all successful businesses rely on repeat
business
which is only possible with high levels
of customer satisfaction
this is a real discipline
what is the key to long-term
profitability the answer is
recommendations and referrals
the ultimate question that determines
the long-term success or failure of your
business is
based on your experience with us
would you recommend us to others
you can only survive and thrive when the
majority of your customers are so happy
with your products and services that
they will encourage their friends and
associates to buy from you as well
since a referral from a satisfied
customer is 15 times easier to sell to
than a cold call
which means it only costs 1 15 as much
referral business is the key to your
future
you require tremendous focus and
discipline to develop and maintain
customer service policies that cause
people to buy from you then buy again
and recommend you to their
friends set high standards
you require the discipline to set
standards of excellent performance in
every area of your business and then to
continually strive to get even better
you need to practice the cani formula
which stands for continuous and never
ending improvement
no matter how high your level of quality
is today you can never be satisfied you
must be continually raising the bar on
yourself and on everyone within your
area of responsibility
you require the self-discipline to work
long hard hours for many months and even
years to get to the top of your business
the average entrepreneur business owner
or self-made millionaire in america
works 59 hours per week
some entrepreneurs even work 70 to 80
hours per week in the first few years of
building their businesses
you must be prepared to discipline
yourself to put in this amount of time
and level of hard work if you want to be
the best and get to the top of your
field
think about the solution
to succeed in business you need the
self-discipline to be proactive rather
than reactive
you need to focus on solutions rather
than problems you need to concentrate on
the most important thing you could
possibly be doing every hour of every
day rather than getting sidetracked by
low value or no value tasks and
activities
above all you need the self-discipline
to settle in for the long term to
develop a long time perspective in your
business life
because of the intensity of competition
it takes many years of discipline effort
for you to become a business success
whether this is in your own business or
working for someone else
there are no shortcuts there are no easy
ways to get to the top
there is only one way and that is
through hard work discipline and
willpower
on average it takes about two years to
break even in a new business venture
it takes another two years of positive
cash flow to pay back the money you
borrowed in the first two years
it then takes another three years before
you become truly successful
in addition everything costs twice as
much and takes three times as long
based on these statistics why should you
start your own business or embark on a
new business venture
because the time is going to pass anyway
after all five years from now you will
be five years older
and 10 years from now you will be 10
years older
at the end of that time you will either
be at the top of your field or still
down among the 80 percent struggling for
every dollar and worrying about money
every day
the choice is yours discipline is the
key
in the next chapter you learn the
discipline that controls the lifeblood
of your business
sales
in the final analysis as peter drucker
said the purpose of a business is to
create and keep a customer
now here are some action exercises for
you
number one
stand back and look at every area of
your business as if you were an outside
consultant
what changes would you recommend
two
imagine you were starting your business
over again today
are there any products or services that
you would not bring to the current
market
three
identify the twenty percent of your
products and services that account for
eighty percent of your sales and profits
how could you sell more of them
four
project forward one two and five years
in your business
what are the trends
what will your customers be buying in
the future
five
list three ways you can improve your
customer service to ensure that
customers buy from you again
and tell their friends
six list three ways that you could
attract more and better qualified leads
from your marketing and advertising
activities
and seven list three ways that you could
make more sales to the prospects you
attract or that you could attract more
and better prospects
chapter 11
self-discipline and sales
nothing happens until a sale takes place
read motley
the most important element in business
success is selling
nothing happens until a sale takes place
all the factories businesses offices and
producers of goods and services only
leap into action when someone somewhere
makes a sale to someone
selling is one of the hardest
professions in america
it is also the only profession in which
a person can start with limited skills
to achieve one of the highest incomes in
our economy
moving onward and upward in sales is
like driving on the autobahn in germany
there are no speed limits you can go as
far and as fast as you want by stepping
on the accelerator of your own ambition
and determination to excel in the
profession of sales
business success or failure
thousands of bankrupt or insolvent
companies have been analyzed over the
years to determine why they failed
after all the data was sorted and
studied virtually every business failure
came down to one reason
low sales
in contrast whenever a business was
succeeding growing yielding
profitability increasing its share
prices and offering opportunity for more
and more people the reason boiled down
to one factor
high sales
everything else was secondary
almost everything you do in a business
either increases or decreases sales
everything either helps or hurts
everything either attracts or keeps more
customers or drives them away
everything counts when it comes to sales
the discipline of generating sales
whether you are a salesperson or a
business owner you require the
self-discipline to focus and concentrate
on generating sales every hour of every
business day
a group of researchers interviewed
several hundred senior executives and
business owners and asked them
how important is sales and marketing to
your business
without exception they all replied sales
and marketing is absolutely essential to
our survival and growth
the researchers then conducted a time
and motion study of these same business
owners and executives
following them around and tracking their
time usage over the course of a month at
the end of that time they completed
their calculations and determined that
the average business owner or executive
who professed that sales were absolutely
essential to survival and growth
was spending only 11 percent of his time
on sales and marketing
the remaining time was spent on meetings
discussions paperwork administrative
work luncheons and a variety of other
activities that contributed nothing to
sales generation
if you're a sales manager or business
owner you must discipline yourself to
focus most of your time and attention on
getting your sales people to generate
the sales on which your company depends
you must spend 75 percent of your time
working with your sales people
accompanying them when they visit your
customers and make presentations and
sales
do your paperwork before or after work
but during working hours when customers
are available to be seen you should
dedicate yourself entirely to sales
generation
how to go broke
some years ago i started a new business
i developed the product and then began
advertising via direct mail radio
television and newspaper
i allowed myself to be completely
overwhelmed with planning paperwork and
advertising activities
by the end of the year i was out of
money and my business was almost broke
at that time i realized that i had taken
my eye off the ball of sales i then sat
down over christmas and designed a
complete sales process
on january 2nd i picked up the telephone
and began making appointments
over the next two months of aggressive
and focused sales activity i did more
business than i had done over the entire
previous year
i saved my business and my home and i
never lost sight of that focus again
one of the most important questions you
can ask as a salesperson entrepreneur or
business owner is whether
what i'm doing right now is leading to a
sale
ask this question of yourself repeatedly
throughout the day
every time the answer comes up no
you must immediately stop whatever you
are doing of lower value and turn your
attention to sales generation
in addition make sure that all the
people who are responsible for sales in
your company ask and answer this
question in the affirmative all day long
overcome your fear of rejection
assuming that you have an attractive
product or service one that is
reasonably priced and suited to the
current market
the biggest problem that telephone sales
people and outside sales people face is
rejection
the fear of rejection does more to
sabotage a sales career and
undermine sales activities than any
other single factor it is the major
obstacle to sales success
it takes tremendous discipline for
salespeople to get up every morning and
go out and face the inevitable rejection
that they know they're going to receive
all day long
most people cannot handle this
continuous rejection
therefore to avoid the emotional pain
that comes with rejection many
salespeople engage in a series of
displacement activities to avoid being
rejected
first of all they make fewer calls
according to columbia university the
average salesperson works about 90
minutes per day
in other words only about one and a half
hours out of an eight hour day
they spend the rest of the time warming
up and getting ready shuffling paperwork
checking the internet reading the
newspaper chatting with co-workers
coming in late leaving early and taking
extended lunches and coffee breaks
as a result by the end of the day on
average the salesperson has worked only
90 minutes
increase face time with customers and
prospects
when as a salesperson actually working
the salesperson is only working when he
or she is ear to ear on the phone or
face to face with someone who can and
will buy within a reasonable period of
time
the rule for sale success can be
contained in six words
spend more time with better prospects
there's no other way to generate a high
consistent and predictable level of
sales results
because of the fear of rejection however
salespeople procrastinate delay
throughout the sales day
doing everything possible to avoid
getting face-to-face with people who can
say no
the key to sales success as i learned as
a young salesman is to realize that
rejection is not personal
prospective customers always say things
like no i'm not interested or variations
of i don't want it i don't need it i
can't use it i can't afford it i'm not
in the market right now or
i'm happy with my existing supplier
the professional sales person realized